following is a conversation with jimmy
pedro a legendary judo competitor and
coach he represented the united states
at four olympics in 92 96 2000 2004
winning a bronze medal at two of them
he meddled in three world championships
winning gold in 1999.
he has coached many of the elite level
american judoka including kayla harrison
ronda rousey travis stevens and many
others
plus he's now my judo coach along with
travis stevens
this is the lex friedman podcast to
support it please check out our sponsors
in the description and now here's my
conversation with jimmy
pedro
what is the most beautiful throw in judo
to you
i think uchimara
you know it's the it's the one that
seems to have the most amplitude the
person goes the highest you see a leg
swing through the middle
uh the person doing the throw there's a
leg swinging through the middle the
other person definitely goes you know
head over heels flat on their back um
it's probably the most dynamic pretty
judo throw there is
okay so it's a single you're standing on
a single foot and you're raising your
other foot in the air and it's a forward
throw which means the uh
your your back is facing the opponent
but uh they kind of
both fly through the air and twist
through the air correct
yeah so how does that throw
work what are the principles behind that
throw is one of those throws that um
you know people can kind of understand
how to pick up another human being in
sort of trivial ways but the h mata to
me never quite made sense
like why it works
there's there's a cork there's a
twisting motion
there's some involvement of the hip but
not it's not really a hip throw
because the hip is not all the way over
so it's not it it's a very confusing
throat
can you say something probably one of
the most difficult throws to learn as
well because it is so complex you do
have to stand on one leg balance on one
leg you know swing your other leg
through the middle hold your opponent up
in the air and it's and it's hard to
it's hard to make that contact with
upper body to your to your back you know
you have to turn your back on the throw
as well so how does it work um it's
definitely sort of a throw where you
need to start pulling your opponent's
upper body towards you
right so their upper body starts coming
towards you your legs go towards them as
your body starts to go
to into the throw so your head is going
to go left let's say your body your legs
are going to go to the right your body's
your partner is going to start to lean
towards you and just as you start to get
their momentum coming forward
your leg is going to sweep up underneath
theirs pick them up onto your hip right
and then the finish of the throw is a
twist and a lot of times the good jadoka
will leave their feet when they do the
throw so both bodies are in the air
together and then the thrower comes down
on top of the person being thrown so all
four feet are in the air correct so
there's just this unstoppable forces
twist so you're all in the air you're
basically doing a roll together correct
okay so who to you is the best uchimada
who has the besides yourself
i'm not gonna lie there's there's plenty
of guys that do shimada a lot better
than i do uh you do have a nice video
about the chamada online but uh
who who's a great practitioner of the
ichimodo team right now shohei ono who's
two-time olympic gold medalist that's
his favorite throw and he there's a
tons of highlight videos on the igf and
judo fanatic showing how he does his
uchimara and it is quite different than
everybody else's um but it's unstoppable
when when he comes in nobody stops it
he's won two goals in a row at the
olympics i think maybe in the last eight
years the guy's lost two matches you
know he's just incredible so at a very
competitive division i guess 73 kilos
okay and then three
three-time world champ too is he the
greatest of all time
do you
the only reason why he's not is because
nomura is a 60 kilo player he was
three-time olympic champion
so no more i mean unless ono's gonna
stick around for another three years and
win again and uh
win again here in paris that's you know
then he'd match what nomura did but
three-time gold medalist in judo in a
lightweight division
that's pretty spectacular
so to you the
the being able to win a championship
world championship or olympic medal
is a measure of greatness it's not like
um
you have some people who are not as
accomplished like koga or something like
that but just
the the beauty
uh the the moments of magic the number
of moments of magic is the highest even
if it's not championships i think you
have to go by that because there's so
many phenomenal judo players that have
come through the system of spectacular
judo um
you have one you know countless major
events but you know the ability to pull
it together right at those magical
moments the the pinnacle of the sport
the world championships the olympic
games and proving that you can do it
time and time again
makes you unstoppable it makes you the
best um you know there was a guy back in
the
70s and 80s by the name of fuji and he
won four
world championships back to back and
back then the worlds was every two years
so he was here he was a four-time world
champion that's eight years the top of
the sport
he never
uh won an olympic medal
you know he never went to the olympics
you know so there's a guy who missed out
on on olympic greatness but was
arguably the best competitor back in
that that period by the way same
fuji as
as fuji
right really okay wow i didn't know that
was an actual guy fuji our brand is is
named after the mountain mount fuji okay
but you know this is a different guy his
name was future all right well
um history rhymes
what about
teddy renair ten-time world champ i
think two-time gold medalist at the
olympics two times bronze medalist at
the olympics
probably the most dominant judoka ever
is he in the running what do you think
about that guy
i think he's a a freak of nature teddy
you know if you look at the size just
how big he how tall he is how big he is
how physical he is of a specimen like i
sat next to him on a bus
and
like his legs are literally the size of
my waist yeah like when you sit next to
him and just look at the side he's a big
man
you know so
obviously to win 10 world titles in the
sport of judo i mean it that's uh that's
almost an incomprehensible feat uh
two-time olympic champion again
um but
you know that puts him in one of the
maybe 10 or 12 people that ever do that
in the history of the sport so
he's definitely got to be in the running
for for the best but
you know technically i don't think he's
as technical as some of the other um
in terms of pure judo
finesse technique you know it's he's
powerful he's explosive he's dominant
he's strong um
teddy also grips really really well
which makes him
that much tougher to beat because a lot
of times heavyweights especially the
heavyweight division a lot of them just
grab the ghee and they go you know man
to man and judo to judo and take shots
at each other and that's why a lot of
them end up getting beat but teddy's in
control like positionally he stays in
really good position and he controls his
opponent the whole fight so they really
don't have a chance against them he
doesn't give them a chance to beat him
which is why he's been so dominant but
he's not really stalling
so i mean he does have a really nice uh
sort of gary this uh
backward trip
outside trip in case people don't know i
mean he has
just like technically pretty good throws
and for heavyweight yes heavyweights can
be sometimes messy
with their uh judo he's pretty
technical
and uh clean
in the execution of his big throws but
a lot of that probably has to do with
the dominant gripping that he does it's
not defensive gripping it's offensive
gripping but the dominant gripping 100
he he controls the grips he controls the
movement of the match as a result of
that and then he creates his own
openings so i mean as a for a
heavyweight phenomenal technique yes
um and what you said messy i'd like to
call it sloppy right a lot a lot of the
uh heavyweights tend to be sloppy
they've fallen on the ground a lot
it's hard to move somebody that weighs
350 pounds you know it's hard to get
that body moving and just with the
simple uh pull motion so
um he's definitely found a way to do it
but he's also i don't know six foot
eight yeah you know he's probably weighs
140 kilos he's a big boy and but he had
this winning streak of just uh i don't
know how long but like over 100 matches
and he lost at this uh olympics that we
just went through the 20 i don't even
know what to call it 2021 olympics i
don't know the proper terminology tokyo
2020 okay 2020. all right
so he lost to uh tamerlan bashev
i mean it's always sad to see a sort of
greatness come to an end it's like uh
corellon and wrestling and greco-roman
did you shed a bit of a tear to see
greatness go or um
like
or is it just the way of life
um i mean what did you think about sort
of this dominance this run of dominance
being stopped
i think i mean it's obviously sad to see
i love seeing champions succeed um
especially people that that are good
people and i think teddy's a good person
you know i mean i think there's some
arrogant champions that everybody would
like to see lose just because they don't
want to deal with their um you know
their personality or
but and i think but i think teddy's a
very humble champion you know he's a
people's champion you know he's
i think he's been privileged and he
makes good money from the sport of judo
and the french federation has taken care
of him well so he's a he's a lifelong
judo icon
um so it's sad to see somebody like that
get beat especially when this could have
been you know his his third olympic
title and
um
you know just
beco put him in infamy you know so it
was sad to see but i think you know
every athlete
goes through it right i mean you
it's just that's what the olympics is
all about the great ones fall sometimes
and um especially in judo right it's
like so
like the margin of error i mean i guess
the other question i want to ask here is
in your sense how difficult it is to not
lose for
so long
it seems like in judo like a little
mistake
and it's over
there's no there's no coming back any
pawn means it's over so how difficult is
that is
it's hard to stay that dominant without
question first of all when you are when
you are the entire world is is training
against you just to be right they're
studying every single
movement they're they're studying
patterns they're they're trying to break
it down and find a flaw in your game
so everybody's hunting for you when
you're the best in the world especially
at the olympics that's that's the that's
the one to beat you at so
everybody's focused on you and then
there's an incredible amount of pressure
on that athlete to perform you know you
carry the flag for your country you know
when you're in opening ceremonies
sometimes you know there's
all spotlight is on you um and it's
particularly hard when things don't go
well early
you know in other words when you're
expected to win and then all of a sudden
now you're in a hard fight and it's not
going the way you want that pressure the
one who's the favorite feels the
pressure the most at the olympics and
that's why i think the other ones are
able to win it
i've actually never gotten a chance to
listen to teddy renair sort of explain
uh ideas behind his judo like i wonder
what his mental game is like because i
think his english is pretty not very
good
and so
um and i just haven't seen good
interviews but it's always fascinating
to
there's certain great athletes that are
also great thinkers and speakers
like um the satia brothers in wrestling
again not meaning that that's on my
to-do list 100
i'm going to afghanistan and talking to
them because they're brilliant
but to be able to sort of
um maybe after retirement to to think
back what were the systems involved
both on the technical
the training side
and then the uh mental side because like
to stay that dominant just like you're
saying everybody's studying to beat you
and
and the heavyweights are just these
powerful dudes so
to be able to control them with your
game and like the game that everybody
knows is coming is
i don't know i don't know what's behind
that but there's got to be um
it feels like the mental game is
exceptionally important
i think a lot of people underestimate
just how important that that side is
meant being mentally prepared for
victory mentally prepared to be the best
to stay the best um
there's nobody that's weak minded that
they can accomplish that you know it's
it's a hundred percent confidence and
belief in yourself
if we take a big picture of you then not
necessarily tater in there but
if you want to go from the very
beginning from day one of judo class to
olympic champion
or olympic medalist
what does it take
to become an olympic medalist in judo
from start to finish
like how many different trajectories do
you see or is there some
unifying principles
i think a lot of it has to your journey
is going to depend a lot by where you're
from
so a path that an american might take
versus somebody who's from japan or
somebody who's from europe there's two
very just three very distinct paths
right
because
you know in japan it's it's part of the
culture it's there's a there's a system
of excellence there's you know there's
elementary school judo there's junior
high school there's high school there's
collegiate there's olympic and
you know
much like our wrestling is here in our
in the united states right it's very
similar there's youth wrestling there's
high school this ncaa and then there's
olympic wrestling and you know when you
when you your country is a factory of
producing athletes at the highest level
then all of those top athletes typically
go back into the sport and there's
professions for them they have an
opportunity to coach at all those
different levels and just the level of
their game and the expertise that all of
them have even down at the elementary
level make their skill
so solid and as a coach in that
situation you can just sit back
and watch who stands out
as opposed to i think in america i guess
you need to
craft
you don't get to choose from a thousand
people a few people that naturally stand
out at the age of nine
you get you have to actually
uh
whatever the natural resources you're
given
craft them into a champion
um
so if we look at that the american way
where you just have a person with a
smile show up show up to your dojo says
i wanted to be an olympic medalist
what process do you take them through
well the odds are really insurmountable
like it's it's a very very high hill to
climb uh and there's only a few i think
only a few people and there's only a few
coaches in this entire country that
really understand that process
and they can that can help people reach
that level as as it's been proven right
yeah um number one you you certainly
have to have a solid base a fundamental
base of of an expectation of what the
training is going to be
and it has to be a level of
professionalism very very early where
you're teaching all the basic judo moves
all the basic fundamental movements
posture
gripping
well maybe gripping doesn't come in so
early in the game but um throwing
methodology movements nawaza position
um standing fundamental throws and i
think most importantly is really the
work ethic just the way you're going to
train the intensity you're going to
train with the ability to
the you know mindset of going to
tournaments constantly you need you know
in order to compete with the rest of the
world
our young kids need to
be tested
a lot when they're young they have to be
put through adversity because they don't
get put through adversity and training
because you don't have that many good
training partners so you get put through
adversity in competition and then do we
see what your weaknesses are and we
continue to make improvements on those
um but the journey is is it's long and
and until they're kind of at the teenage
years they're going to have to pretty
much stay domestic right because they
got to go through life as a normal kid
but they've got to be training in the
dojo at least you know five days a week
you know sometimes they might want to
get you know an extra technical workout
in or doing some base conditioning in
addition to that and then really at the
teenage years that's where we really
um we've struggled in america of of
keeping teens in the sport of judo as
well as developing them properly because
up until around the teenage years i
think the americans are on par with the
rest of the world in terms of technique
and in terms of skill and
you know we've we've proven we can
compete with the rest of the world up
until that age but
that's where japan and that's where the
europeans and the countries that are
strong in judo that's where they put a
lot of time energy and effort is into
the teens
where they have a great coaching staff
they have good training camps with with
800 a thousand people going to them
every single weekend
um when you say teens what do you mean
do you mean literally like 13 yeah
13 to 17 13 to 19. and that's where sort
of that's when you really accelerate
your development so you're saying like
in america
when you're young
like before you know
9 10 11 12 you stick in judo you can
progress quite a bit right but then i
guess the other competition there
if you're into uh
two people
uh
you know doing stuff to each other in a
combative way
uh the other competitor in america is
wrestling
so judo almost primes you like it
teaches you uh how to be a great
wrestler as well and so then you have to
have a hard decision
because you can probably be a collegiate
wrestler
you can you can you have like a a clear
plan
of where you're going to go if you want
to be a wrestler with judo
that plan is more um
is less clear
so yeah you have to be on your own a bit
with your coach that kind of thing
exactly
okay so when you're on your own with
your coach to me that's just a
fascinating journey because then it's
just like the purity of it it's the
coach and the athlete and the dream
it's all about the dedication the the
five six seven days a week
competing what once a month
twice a month
okay and just but also you probably
don't have that conversation i don't
know if you do maybe you do
saying like we're gonna do this for the
next eight years
right do you ever sit down would you
just do it take it to david goggins way
which is like let's just take it one
step at a time
let's hope we're there in eight years
yeah let's hope we're there do you
actually like right now you have to
think about
the olympics is gonna be in in los
angeles in 2028 so it's really
interesting now now would be the time
and now is the time
to identify talent
and get commitment out of students
that in seven years you can make a u.s
olympic team because we're going to have
a full team
america is going to have 14 athletes
compete in those games one in every
weight class so now is the time if
you're going to go on a journey to the
olympics and stay with the sport of judo
now would be the time to do it
you know and so what uh
you show up to the pedro judo center and
how much drilling how much
techniques strategy discussions how much
randori or like live sparring how much
conditioning and strength training
how much of all that
how much of cross training to other gyms
or something like that traveling
abroad is there something to be said
about us um some aspects of that system
for sure um you need it all what you
just said we needed all of it and we do
do all of that right now we have a young
group of kids at the academy you'll see
tonight some of them are 14 13 15 17.
are they good yeah really good okay so
they're gonna get away they're right
around your weight so it'll be perfect
they're just young boys but they've been
training hard through kovid yeah um
we've been travis and myself have been
training them we share responsibilities
um they're doing randori like five
nights a week you know we have them
doing randori tuesdays
wednesdays
thursdays fridays and sundays is when
they're doing randori they're coming to
the dojo friday night and sunday night
to do training
we also have technical sessions for them
and they're in school now so it's a
little bit challenging but they come
five o'clock in the afternoon and they
do a technical session through covid
they were coming every morning doing
technical sessions what's the technical
session you're it's an hour of um
repetitive throwing or repetitive
drilling to to reinforce movements that
we deem important to our successful uh
system so nawaza positions groundwork
positions where we want them to be put
in this position and they're going to
drill it 50 times you know with
resistance in big groups you know doing
drills over and over again picking apart
the details of the technique and what
they're doing wrong showing them how to
fix it but now we've done it so much
that now we can do a whole drill session
with them where they know all the
different techniques inside and out and
they can move from position to position
really quickly do they do it for uh a
period of time like two minutes five
minutes or is it like one do they're
actually counting no sometimes it's both
so sometimes we do it for reps sometimes
we do it for time
yeah so sometimes it might be as many as
they can do in in 60 seconds or as many
as they can do in two minutes and
sometimes it might just be i want you to
do every position five times
in terms of throws
we're not talking about on a crash pad
right it's it's just we're talking about
free moving around the mat and just
dynamically and just throwing correct
how many uh
because uh as i was mentioning to you
offline
uh travis threw me a few times
a lot of times when he was visiting in
austin and i just remembered uh so
there's two things i
fortunately or unfortunately in my life
haven't gotten a chance to train with
folks of that level without just
cleanness of throw and the power and it
was very nice i can i immediately
actually enjoyed being thrown like that
to throw a little [ __ ] at craig jones
with his current matt situation um is
they're very they were quite thin
uh and as travis commented on and not
just the thinness of the mats but they
were laid on like concrete right so i
felt i felt it's like soft until it's
not um
but uh
being thrown very cleanly i just felt
like there's this is not gonna lead to
injury it was great it wasn't injury
prone but then as i mentioned to you
when i a day or two after my entire leg
one of them i guess it's the left leg
um
was just in just black bruise
it didn't it didn't hurt too bad it was
just the body's gotten soft so i guess
the question is um
does the body get used to
just that number of throws just over
time being thrown thousands of times a
month
unquestionably your body gets used to it
so it hardens it gets really hard which
is why judo is is hard to come back to
after you've taken a long period of time
off because your body is not used to
that impact anymore
um i always found out that you know when
i was training judo a lot it's hard to
it's hard to shed weight and keep weight
off because your body like you know it
it develops like this layer of
protection on itself that it doesn't
want to give up yeah you know when
you're sucking a lot of weight that
means you're frail and you know so i
always seem to
retain weight more you know when you're
doing hard judo training as opposed to
you know losing weight it's easy when
you go for runs and things like that to
shed the water weight but to actually
keep the pounds off was yeah pretty hard
yeah the body kind of develops like you
said a level of protection what about
the randori just out of curiosity again
i i haven't ever had the opportunity to
train with folks at a high level
um it's you know in jiu jitsu
the there's different gyms have
different styles but i've noticed that
at the highest levels people
can go pretty hard in a certain kind of
way where it's more technical and you're
not you're moving at a hundred percent
but the power is not at a hundred
percent
it's it's a weird little dance it's it's
techn like you're not really
um
forcing stuff you're more focused on on
the right timing the right
uh positioning of hands and feet and
body and all those kinds of things
you're not like forcing stuff in the way
you would in competition like really the
power does that sound similar to you for
the way you tried to durandori so
there's different styles of judo and
they say the japanese style the
technical style of judo is exactly what
you just talked about it's like it's
almost like two guys in pajamas right
we're not going we're not using it we're
using minimal effort maximum efficiency
we're moving around and we're trying to
feel that movement
and it's timing and finesse and
technique and fun and clean throws and
when you you know when you train in
japan
you can train 15 rounds of randori five
minute rounds that's 75 minutes of of
straight you know sparring you can do
that straight in japan without a problem
i mean you'll get tired of course you're
going to fall a lot you're going to
throw a lot
but it's very like free feeling
and it's technical as you explained but
then when you go to europe and you try
to do rounds with the europeans they are
very physical they don't have that same
finesse in their training that they do
in japan and in europe you'd be
hard-pressed to do eight rounds of
randori in a night it's so physically
exhausting because so much effort is
going into just fighting and fending off
the gripping system and the power of
your opponent you're physically drained
after eight rounds of randori so it's a
much different feel when you say europe
do you mean germany france britain
russia is there a lot so
there's a kind of
similarity to all of those kinds of
approaches the only difference would be
russia that they do a lot more active
drilling a lot more sequential movement
training they don't focus as much on
randori you'll do much fewer rounds in
russia
during training camps than you would in
in those other countries we just talked
about france germany etc what about in
this kind of american system where you
have much less talent
uh to work with is
did you uh
just select whatever works for the
particular athletes or do you have a
something you prefer in your system
so you need a combination of all of it
if you're going to win at the olympic
level you have to be able to deal with
the finesse of the japanese the
physicality of the europeans you have to
focus on on the ground nawaza aspect
because a lot of people are weak there
in the world of the sport of judo that's
a chance to win
we've sort of developed our american
system of judo at least for the last i
say probably the last 20 years would be
the american system of judo which relies
heavily on taking the individual and
whatever techniques they they do
perfecting those techniques and
the combinations and other throws that
go with those throws but then
implementing and overlaying an american
system of gripping nawaza conditioning
mentality training methodology
like in in game planning you know to
beat your opponents and i think that's
the that's the secret sauce to success
for the fair americans because there's
no way if we don't have eight partners
to train within the night that are going
to give us good rounds right we might
have two
you know so we know the same guy four
times those two people four you know two
times each now i have four good rounds
the rest of the rounds i'm not being
pushed to the limit so we train
differently
um and a lot of times we do a lot of
stuff like shark bait when our athletes
are preparing for competition for
example when kayla or travis were
preparing for competition
we might only have 20 people in the
whole gym work to work out with those
two
olympic medalists right and of those 20
people maybe four of them are travis's
size you know maybe there's only one
girl in the room for kayla she's got to
train with guys and then the other ones
are teenagers that are too weak to train
with either one of them so what we would
do is just put together four or five
people that could you know give them a
challenge and we'd line them up and they
would do a minute a minute a minute a
minute and then do five minutes in a row
as hard as they can
that person can go hard for a minute
with travis or kayla they can't go five
minutes hard but they can go one minute
hard so it made their training much
much more intense much more physically
demanding and then rinse and repeat that
six times or eight times in a night
you know they just got 40 minutes of
intense randori the person that was
training with them that wasn't as good
only had to do six or eight minutes of
training the whole night yeah you know
so
it's so
it's so difficult
because you then you look at like
the russian national team
and you have just world champions and
so
um
or you even have like um what is the tom
brands and terry brands in the in the
wrestling system you have like
these people it's a small group of
people but they're all some of the best
people in the world and they're going
head to head and yeah you don't
necessarily get a good look kind of a
variety of styles
but just the qualities there and even
that is missing for people your size in
america because
and that is so difficult to work with we
should make scales and makes travis's
story that much more amazing
is um you mentioned kind of
picking whatever the set of techniques
the athlete
is naturally good at or prefers or
whatever
how much specialization is there
maybe if i give you like two choices is
it good to have like one throw
and try to become the best person in the
world at that throw or do you want to
have a bunch of stuff
uh like a a variety of throws well for
travis it was he pulling saying aggie
that was his main throw right but from
that ipo and saying he had a variety of
other attacks he could do
you know that mixed it up so that you
kept people guessing that maybe it
wasn't the paul and say we was coming
maybe it was the koshi grumma that he
did or maybe it was the ipone to osoto
that he did in combination so you
typically have one main
throw that you do for me it was tai
otoshi for kayla it was her ogoshi for
travis it was ipo and sanagi but then
you come up with a variety of other
throws that you do from the very same
grip so whatever grip you take for your
main throw you want to develop you know
an arsenal of attacks that go in all
different directions holding that same
grip so you keep your opponent guessing
as to what's coming you know because if
they're just sitting on one technique
at the highest level of sport with the
exception of a few right we talked about
ono's uchimada
with the exception of a few most of the
world catches on pretty quick on how to
beat you
there is something to just sticking
making sure you really dedicate to the
main thing so for travis that would be
like the main version of his inagi
like really making sure you don't forget
to really put in the time on that
because um
i mean one one way to say it is
that threat being dangerous opens up a
lot of things right
but also
i don't know
i think i'm just as a fan i think it
it's sad when like elite level athletes
in in all like combat sports
kind of start taking their main thing
for granted
like um they think okay i've i figured
that part out
now i'll be working on all this whole
system on variations on different setups
on
uh lefty versus some like weird
variation as opposed to
you know what if you look at some of the
best people ever they seem to have not
cared about variations at all
they're just like literally
they are more like jiro dreams of sushi
and like
like fine-tuning their ear their ability
to detect the mine movements that give
you an opening on that main thing and so
the whole time you're just
waiting for that throw you're like
dancing with the like little bit of
pressure
and like releasing the pressure and
putting the pressure maybe a little bit
off off balance and finding like the
right
moment to strike and
focusing on that again maybe that's just
like a romanticization of like
the simplicity of that maybe it is kind
of impossible to do that on a large
scale but i just um
[Music]
yeah i i don't know if you can comment
on that whether there is some value and
still putting in like tens of thousands
of reps on the main main thing well
unquestionably that has to happen you
still have to drill your main throw and
you have to fine tune it and continue to
do you know repetition after repetition
and throws on the crash pad you know or
throws on the mat moving around just
explosive movements doing your main
technique you're never going to forget
that and you're not going to put it to
the side and not practice it anymore it
still has to be part of your repertoire
and part of your daily training but you
do have to evolve and i think that's and
i think that's the sport of judo makes
you evolve you know when i look at we
talk about koga from before right and we
talked about he had a dynamic he pulling
say in agi that nobody could stop for
years and years and years but
when people started to you know be
unorthodox and come down his back and
cross-grip him and he couldn't get to
the lapel he had to come up with
something else and all of a sudden you
saw koga doing now he did a soda where
now he did a tomo nagi which so he can
he added to his arsenal you know to keep
people thinking keep purple gas in so
it's not you're not just that one trick
pony they still couldn't stop his ipo
and say
once he got that grip but if they stop
them from getting that grip or putting
two hands on the ghee he had to go to
something else and that's what he did
does travis's or koga's say nagi make
sense to you
that weird uh so when i because split
hip that's
split hip so
i don't know if you know this but like i
got into judo because of travis i
watched him with 2008 olympics and i was
uh there's something about like
uh just the not the cockiness but the
confidence and just the refusal to quit
the refusal to just some that energy
whatever you connect to me is like oh
that guy's badass
i want to be badass like that
and then i also there happened to be in
my university judo and i um
and i got into and just fell in love
with the elegance and the beauty and the
power of the sport um
but also i started to mimic travis's
game
uh his and koga's
and i and then uh the instructors i
worked with they said that's the wrong
way to do it
and i always i never found somebody that
told me that like
no that's not the wrong way to there's a
lot of ways to do it and there's like
the classic way and you have to
understand and you have to learn it but
this is not the wrong way because i was
trying to find somebody who understands
this throw
because it's so
beautiful at the highest level
especially with koga the way
you're able the quickness with which you
can strike the fact that you could stand
on the feet and the elevation you can
get and the power you can get it has
certain throws
just
like uchamata doesn't look powerful
it it's just like it's it looks
effortless
but like
the standing sanagi with a split hip it
just looks powerful because
there's a
you're like you're stepping into them
you're lifting the opponent and they
still have they're not surprised they're
now like helpless right their feet are
fluttering and flattering so and then
there's just this this pause and then
just big slam with the ucha mata it's
almost like you don't know what hit you
that's like tayatoshi is the same it's
almost like a surprise like oh [ __ ] i'm
not on my back and
um
so i i just i just
love that throw but like
i it didn't make sense to me
like
when trying to explain it to others when
trying to learn it didn't make sense to
me uh how it works does it make sense to
you it does yeah i'm i was born a judoka
right so i i've lived this stuff since i
was
an infant and i've seen every style and
every technique um
the split hip saying aggie is is
difficult to learn it's harder to learn
than the the basic form but it is
powerful and it does
upon entry
both your opponent's feet leave them out
at the same time so you've got them once
you enter you've got them you just got
to finish right you just got to lock
them and turn and go so
it makes sense to me my dad did teach me
how to do that when i was younger yeah
he wanted me to do a split hip we have
kids at the school today that we teach
the split up say in aggie same way
um because it is that dynamic right you
don't drop to the ground and roll and
turn it's not the classic form where
you're giving way to your opponent it's
actually you go pick the guy up in the
air and then you slam them so
okay uh
beautiful so maybe on a small tangent so
we're talking about elite level athletes
in terms of randori in terms of rep like
uh drilling
for more recreational athletes
like
you know i have personally that
situation going on but there's other
people there just recreationally
training judo how do you recommend they
improve judo like
if i wanted to compete a bunch
and do reason reasonable with a
particular set of throws say the split
uh
senagi
how do you do you do the randori do you
use a crash brad to get him reps do you
like what do you recommend so i guess
there's two recreational people that
we're talking about one is somebody who
wants to learn judo and become good at
judo but don't doesn't necessarily want
to compete but just wants to get better
and i think that there's not enough
emphasis
in this country on
just that on paying attention to that
type of student everybody pushes them to
competition but in reality there's a
huge audience of people out there that
would love to learn judo and be very
proficient at judo and have the skills
to go execute if they ever needed it
and there's a class and there should be
a program for that athlete and that
athlete does not need to do randori
like the sport of judo is physical
enough when you're picking somebody up
all the time and moving their body
weight around the mat all the time where
you can get very physically strong very
physically fit technically you'll be
better than somebody that does randori
more than you because you're move if you
learn good technique and you learn the
movement and you learn the feel and you
move the learn the timing
you'll actually be a better athlete than
the person that just focuses on randori
who does ugly technique and wins with
force so you know we have a recreational
class at our school
where they don't do any randori they
have an option afterwards if they want
to stay for 15 minutes or stay for 30
minutes where they can participate in
randori but most of the adult students
choose not to because they're already so
tired from the other you know good
workout right they're already dripping
sweat they're already like if you if you
you know work hard and drill hard it's
an intense workout you're exhausted
you know so that that's a specific
set of of a program i should say at
every academy and then if you want to
get good and you want to compete
then to me once you have your techniques
it's learning how to
implement a good gripping system to put
yourself in a position where you can
always you know dominate the grips
control the movement initiate the
reactions from your opponent and then
have the opportunity to attack and score
and and i think that when people train
with or when they jump into a higher
level of the sport of judo all of a
sudden the first thing they say is i
can't attack
i don't know how to attack because
positionally they don't know where to
put their hands they don't know how to
hold the ghee properly they don't
understand that they're
you know they have an inferior grip
and and they don't know how to get into
better position so they can attack and
that's a big part of the game that not a
lot of people really understand so you
really even for recreational competitors
you really need to have a gripping
system you need to understand the
gripping system
if you want to win yeah i mean if the
goal is to go and compete that's a
different story you're going i don't
have fun getting beat up or losing in
competitions i
enjoy the
i don't even know if it's the winning or
the losing i don't
i i think
this is what because i competed a lot in
both judo and jiu jitsu and in judo
it feels like because i didn't have a
gripping system it feels like you're not
even playing judo against the the good
black belts you're they're just they're
not they're not even trying because they
have they get a certain kind of grip and
you just can't do anything and i don't
have a good answer for that i don't even
know what i'm looking for and so it's
not even fun it's not like even losing
it's it's like um
i don't know it's like you didn't even
show up to play
is what it feels like and it's
unfortunate i i think that is a big gap
in knowledge actually
in um
judo schools
is is the gripping part
when you first go out to to do judo
right you the first thing you have to do
is you have to grab your opponent right
and a lot of times i hear coaches say
get a grip just take a grip well
sometimes if you take a grip
you're in a worse position than not
having a grip at all that's what a lot
of people don't understand like if you
hold the ghee in the wrong way your
opponent can attack you but you can't
attack him so why would you ever do that
grip
if it's only to your detriment
right so that's and
the way you grip does set up
what attacks you can do as well so that
is a huge part and i'm not saying that
you have to be 100 disciplined and only
always out grip your opponent and only
be able to do throws when you have a
superior grip i'm just saying that
to be able to put the grips together
with the throws and understand the
movements is going to make you that much
ahead of the game
so if we take a step to uh our previous
discussion of going from
zero to hero
so going from the the early days through
the teenage years to winning
an olympic medal
so we mentioned
a lot of training the dedication of the
training
the competing what other elements are
there the mental side is uh
visualization believing that you could
perform at that level
uh so what else can you say about it i
think that comes at the highest level
the the visualization the success that
comes at the highest level i think in
the teen years um
there's the experience just plays a huge
role in getting to
train with other people like as
americans we have to go train in europe
we have to feel the european style of
judo we have to
understand that physicality they they
grip very differently they put you in
very unorthodox positions and if you
when if you don't know how to deal with
that you get thrown before you even have
a chance to try your own throws you know
so it takes a lot of
it takes a lot of that experience and
understanding what's going on
and then you also need to get that
physicality you need to be physically
strong and hard i would say by doing all
those rounds with the europeans and at
the same time you need to go to asia and
you need to train in in japan because
you need to feel that free-flowing
judo for your technical the technical
side i think that's
one of the things that i was able to
benefit from my dad was a coach who said
listen i've taken as far as i can take
you i want you to go to the next level i
want you know he sent me to to england
with neil adams who was an olympic
silver medalist and was a world champion
had a great ground game and was good at
gripping and actually did taotoshi which
is the throw i did so my dad said i want
you to go learn from neil and i ended up
going to
to england probably eight to ten times
in my career and spending a good amount
of time there training at the neil adams
academy
um he's now the voice of judo neil adams
what do you make of that guy just a
brief pause he's like the like uh morgan
freeman is the voice of like march of
the penguins and any other nature
documentary and neil adams is uh there's
very few sports that have a neil adams i
would say because
he's legitimately maybe like joe rogan
is that from mixed martial arts it's
just like an exceptionally
recognizable voice he's really
knowledgeable also the passion is
conveyed so well like many times i'll
watch just because he's talking right so
who is he since he got the chance to
train with him to learn from him who's
neil adams he's a great friend of mine
he is he's a mentor
um i like i said i lived and trained at
the neil adams club in coventry england
since i was like 16 years old i went and
visited him for the first time he's the
one who originally taught me how to do
juju gatami and the way that i do
jujigatami
i trained with him he was just retired
he was in his early 30s when i first
went out there and you know so i trained
with him many times and
over the years he's he was a mentor
um great person you know cares that
cares about people cares about you know
the sport of judo
had a good little club that was a
fitness club and you know had it was it
was judo it was fitness it it you know
used to go there i'd show up at that
place at like seven in the morning and
the first thing we would do is we'd go
for a run and we'd either be running
mountains or we'd be doing a five mile
run or we'd be doing something at the
park we were doing sprints and buddy
carries and all this stuff and then at
nine a.m we'd have a technical session
with neil adams where he would you know
for an hour and a half we would drill
techniques and learn positions and it
was no randori it was that sequential
drilling that we talked about before
right where you're
reinforcing your your two or three
attacks to set up your main attack or if
you're on the ground you're going
through repetitions of certain movements
um and then i'd spend all afternoon at
the club have lunch i'd go do my weight
training in the afternoon at that at
that place and then in the evening we
would either do randori training at the
nail adams club or we would all get in a
car and we'd drive to another another
location
you know and we'd go train in another
club that might be an hour away and
there'd be you know 50 bodies there to
train with and each night we'd go to a
different dojo and so it would be all
day at the club and i'd do that for like
three weeks straight you know all we did
was try do you know how he became the
voice of judo do you have an
understanding
of what he's thinking is around like how
much he dedicates to himself
to just uh commentating on jude i
imagine the amount of research required
but also just like psychologically just
the excitement he has in his voice
it it takes work to do that do you have
an understanding of like what his vision
is with that he's always been a very
charismatic animated personnel you know
very passionate and loud and you know
funny and the brits are very funny to
begin with so he's he's you know very
charismatic but um
i think after coaching he tried coaching
he coached the country of wales for a
while he tried coaching stints in other
countries he didn't he didn't have a lot
of success on the coaching side
um developing an olympic champion i know
that some that was a goal of his that he
he was a world champion i think it was
1981 he won two silver medals in the
olympic games um himself
he went on to coach for a while and had
some political issues with the the
country of of england for a while and
then left england and went to wales and
i think he had a coaching somewhere else
as well
didn't have a lot of success coaching in
the sport um with athletes not at the
highest level had a great national team
and things like that he was really good
at
at teaching his technique to others
because he helped me a lot
um
but running a program i think was
difficult for him you know the boy's not
listening and not having that same kind
of passion and intensity that he and
that's why i bonded well with him
because i was all in right i went there
and whatever he said i did i didn't care
how hard i didn't care how long i just
wanted to get as good as i could and so
that's why
he was a good mentor for me
but now in terms of a
commentator
he he's very cerebral he just
he loves judo he he look researches it
non-stop
um he's got that great voice and he
knows how to bring bring life to the
you know to the game and that's what
he's done and now this is who he is
right he he does judo full-time this is
his job can ask you uh a small before we
return to the actual
sport the coaching of the sport
it's a bit of a political question i did
a whole rant before travis episode
uh
i love neil adams's voice i love
watching judo and it's really
disappointing to me that
the ioc
and whoever is responsible i don't
understand this
that they don't make it easy for people
to watch the olympics
uh in replay for years after
like i can't watch travis's matches i
can't walk like it they make it very
difficult to watch stuff online
so what happened is
i uploaded the travis stevens episode
and we talked about his ole bishop 2012
match
and it was like one minute of uh
like a small overlay of the video as
we're talking through it
with like stepping through it and it got
taken down immediately from youtube that
the whole four-hour conversation
because of that one minute little clip
and the way got taken down automatically
is because the ioc has that video
uploaded
it's set to private but it's uploaded
so like they have the video
and they choose not to show it it's not
that they're asking for money or
whatever they're just not showing it
anywhere
they're not showing it through their own
service like an nbc olympics or so on
there's just so many great human stories
that the olympics reveals they're just
not made easily accessible that's the
olympics charter
is you want to i think uh
the actual line is to ensure the fullest
coverage and the widest possible
audience in the world for the olympic
games and it seems like to me as a fan
of the olympic games
we're not getting any of that do you
have an understanding
of why that is like why we can't watch
kayla's matches travis's matches super
easily even if we're willing to pay
money for it
so you you can't go on the international
judo federation website right now and
watch any of the olympic footage no
no no
uh so the only thing they have is for
certain for example teddy renair match
he lost
not available anywhere really and that's
like a dramatic thing so the one thing
they have is for certain sports at the
highest level like gymnastics they'll
have a highlight which is the most
frustrating thing to me
because this is what i can't i'm going
to go like i'm going to try to prevent
myself from going on the rant but
you know
people don't just want to see a
two-minute highlight of a historic
moment
they want to see the build up where the
athlete is standing the nerves the fear
the confidence you see the build-up to
the event say it's a gymnastic
whatever floor routine like
their name is announced they're walking
the coat then they cut to the coach and
the coach with anticipation and then go
to the athlete you want the full 10
minute thing you don't want a two minute
highlight of what happened like last
second or whatever it it it's just like
the magic of that full
story like a lifetime building up to
those 10 minutes
right that that's the magic of the
olympics the both the drama and the
triumph that happens in those moments
and the fact that you can't really
relive that
like travis had a bunch of those right
like he he had a bunch of times he faced
like world champions right he won and
lost and and just it's always close it's
always dramatic right right right and
none of those are available except like
maybe uh
the one would be uh armbard or what
whatever the submission was i forgot the
choke
yeah the the georgia but most things are
not uh usain bolt the full races not all
of us races are available online
um the the race with the italian winning
the 100 meter uh
the
track race
uh this this olympics is not only
highlight is available from what i saw i
didn't look too hard so like but
that the fact that it's not super easily
accessible if you're willing to pay
money even but probably should be for
free is it's heartbreaking to me because
to me the olympics is
like some of the best of humanity
just like again the hardship they have
to overcome so like the losses are
really powerful sure because it's such
heartbreak but it's also like
the triumph we're losing history yeah
you're losing history is what you are of
of all the magical moments of your sport
right it that's that's a it's a sin um
i gotta
blame it on television rights and in in
money that's what it comes down to you
talk on billions and billions of dollars
of television rights paid by nbc here in
the united states and globally whatever
the main carriers are and all the other
nations that are dictating
what can be replayed and what can't and
it's what it comes down to you know i i
made it i made a uh
dvd or you know video when i first
retired from the sport it was called
fury on the mat it was kind of my story
right and i did it with a friend
um who was a videographer and we grabbed
a bunch of my old footage and olympic
footage and
somebody said to me you know you can't
use that olympic footage and you know i
was young and i had just retired i mean
i can't use the olympic footage it's not
it's not the television footage it's my
buddy who filmed it with his own camera
it's my footage yeah exactly you know
and they said no if it has olympics in
it or it's anything to do with the
olympics the usoc owns it yeah i said
okay well they said well you should get
to send it to them and let them you know
review it so i sent it to them and i got
i got a bill back i got a thing back
that said if you want to use this
footage it's going to be like thirty
thousand dollars and i said
but it's only like three minutes i
spliced it up as much as i could and i
only have highlights in there and yeah
and then i said come on i i i went back
and i negotiated with them but at the
end of the day i still have to pay like
fifteen thousand dollars just to have a
few minutes of footage in my own film
this is
and i'm thinking you wouldn't even have
that film if i didn't compete in it you
know like
you can't you know so that was a it was
a struggle this is the different like
you have the same in uh jiu jitsu
there's certain organizations ibbh ibj
jf or like flow grappling and flow
wrestling i understand
i think when it's a business it might
make sense
first of all you should actually be good
at being a business and making money
which is why for me the ioc doesn't make
sense like it should be accessible but
it would cost money
uh if if
i can't buy it like i would would i
would i have to email them for this
footage and pay thirty thousand dollars
yeah no but the the the the question is
that like the way you run a business is
you make that frictionalness you
whatever the money is thirty thousand
dollars or thirty dollars you make it
frictionless and easy to pay that money
but anyway i i understand why that might
be the case will flow grappling but to
me the olympics is a special thing for
sure it's like like you said it is
history like there's not even like the
even the world championships don't
compare i i understand they're they're
really important but
olympics is history and the
the stories should certainly belong to
the athletes if they want to do like
fury on the mat to do their own story or
like on a podcast to talk about the most
uh tragic moment of their career
it
uh do you have a sense of how that could
be fixed
or no
the only thing i could think of is you
know you'd have you'd have to go to the
olympic committee the us olympic
committee is the place i would start
because the us controls the worldwide
market when it comes to television we
pay the most for our television rights
our sponsors
pay the most for their
uh rights to be associated with the best
team in the world which is the united
states right so so all the money starts
here um
i gotta believe there has to be a way to
get that footage that should be
accessible to the sports themselves i'm
surprised it's not but if it's not then
it's because of dollars
you know it's because people aren't the
sport itself is not willing to pay
enough money to have it on its
you know accessible to its audience yeah
it's too cost prohibitive for them to do
it
no but i think it's also unfortunately
might be some mixture of incompetence
and just an old way of doing things
because um
there's a lot of money to be made on
television rights where you like live
show
the event right
but what's not being leveraged is the
huge amount of money that could be made
on the replay this is what people don't
understand
is
do you know how many times
just the tens of millions the the uh of
times that people watch individual
events
years from now
you watch like all the videos on youtube
they're still getting plays hundreds of
millions of views on stuff that happened
10 years ago 15 years ago
that that's really powerful there's a
lot of opportunity to make a ton of
money sure so it's not that they're
necessarily
greedy they're also just not good at
being greedy no i get what you're saying
yeah it's not the tradition you know
think about it though it's not
traditional right for for television
studios it's non-traditional to go to
online streaming to
you know online access to information
it's not hard right because everybody's
doing it now but
it's it's not typical yeah so it's it
requires for the ioc to operate outside
their comfort zone well i definitely
hope that's the case and i
since travis's
video got taken down
it's obvious they have it they have it
on their youtube channel
so it's like um
i'm i hope i hope that they will just
release it and for money for whatever
but release it and have um
that's that uh history not be erased
right it'd be wonderful if athletes
would be could buy there you know even
if you could buy your own footage you
can't use it commercially you can't but
you can you can buy your own matches and
have them available for yourself or
package the you know the the footage it
would be to be awesome
thank you for that that is uh quite
heartbreaking for me so and i wanted to
talk about it a little bit
let's go to
you as an athlete real quick
sure you represented the united states
at four olympics winning a bronze medal
at two of them
who
or what was the toughest match or moment
you had in those years
maybe a moment that defined you
that you remember as being particularly
defining in your career
i would say the the bronze medal match
in atlanta in 96 because up to that
moment the united states team had not
won a medal had not fought for a medal
in the games
we were on our home turf it was my
second olympic games right so i had
competed in 92 and i had won two matches
and and lost in the third round in
barcelona um i didn't make the podium i
lost to a japanese guy from japan
um
but the the gold silver and bronze
medalist at that olympics in barcelona
were all guys that i had beat in fact
two of them i was undefeated against in
my entire career the brazilian and the
cuban i had never lost to
so that's when i knew i was capable of
being
you know on the on the podium at the
olympic games when 96 came around i was
25 years old i was fairly in my prime i
had lived in japan for six months my
technique was at a high level
you know i was i was you know amongst
the best in the world
um
i lost at that olympics to a guy from
mongolia it was right before the match i
was supposed to fight against japan so i
was like anticipating the match against
japan and i got beat by the mongolian
so that was kind of a letdown but
the match for the bronze
you know in front of the hometown crowd
all of my family all of my friends
everybody who would ever help me in my
in the sport were in the stands that day
including all my teammates at brown
university that were on the wrestling
team and little my uncles my aunts
everybody everybody was in the stands
right so it was like the jimmy pedro day
and uh i'm getting goosebumps right now
talking about it
um
but it was a match against the brazilian
for the bronze medal i had beaten the
brazilian like two or three times before
that
um i found myself i found myself down in
the match he actually countered me
um i came in my taotoshi and he was
waiting for it and he counted me and he
scored a yuko against me so i was losing
the fight
came down to about the last minute in
the match
and i was just tucking in my ghee and
fixing my thing and gathering my
thoughts together and the whole crowd
just started chanting usa usa usa and i
like literally like got so much energy i
walked out there i grabbed the guy i
came in my talatosh again he stepped off
the taotosh i threw him with uchimada
free pone
i won my first olympic medal in front of
the hometown crowd
everybody went bananas
you know the united states judo team had
our first medal from the olympics
it ended up being the only olympic medal
we won one at that games but it was like
a magical moment that defined my career
and solidified myself in like history
where hey and now i get to step up on
the olympic podium and i'm olympic
medalist and to me that was
my defining moment and after that i was
sold like man i had to go back to the
olympics again i want to win a gold
medal i want to do i want this feeling
all over again i don't care if i have to
wait four years let's let's do it
in your career
the like moments like that
do you think you love
[Music]
winning or hate losing more
so do you live for those moments
or are you more driven by
just how much you hate losing
so in order to be a champion my belief
is that you have to
hate losing more than you like winning
hate losing more than you like winning
but i live for those moments when you do
win
and what excited me the most in my
career and my when i was
competing was
i loved being in the finals i love the
spotlight being on me i can't think of
too many times in my career of course
there were a few but there weren't too
many times where the chips were down
like the lights were on and i didn't win
like it was
i might have lost early in the day and
didn't make it to the finals or didn't
make it to the metal rounds but like in
my career i have a ton of golds i have a
ton of bronzes which means
the lights are on
and i won and i have very few silvers
and very few fifths
so i either lost in the early rounds and
didn't make to the metal rounds in my
younger days or
the spotlight came and i really shined
because if you look i i don't know how
many silvers but there wasn't very many
silver medals in my career that i want
you know what i mean so
i just loved that moment i didn't feel
pressure i loved the crowd i loved being
in the spotlight i didn't have i wasn't
nervous when it came to the finals or i
knew i was getting a medal it didn't
matter you know so it was just me
against the other guy and that's how i
always saw it and i just loved that
moment
so your dad was your coach
um you gotta get to meet him tonight oh
great
um he's he's kind of a legend in the
sport so how has your dad helped you as
a coach as an athlete as a human being
throughout the years
one my dad is the most brutally honest
person you will ever meet in your life
brutally honest he will tell you a if if
you are fat he will tell you you're fat
right to your face he wants you to get
better he wants you to be healthy yeah
he doesn't want you to die of obesity
right it's just the way he is if you
didn't do well
he will will not sugarcoat it he will
let you know what you didn't do right
and what he's so he's the ultimate
litmus test yes right um
second is he is the most passionate
caring like deep like always thinking
about
very cerebral
very like um studio a student of the
game
somebody who helped me immensely in
divine defining my strategy
um helping me improve and and always you
know look for the what's next
um
in terms of training i think that he's
probably the most brilliant
human when it comes to
preparing an athlete physically
not to say mentally physically for
success
when all the chips are down that athlete
will be ready that day and he has a
system of of training and preparing and
getting the right athlete to peak for
performance you mean like conditioning
like the whole thing yes
okay because i remember like
vaguely remember
kayla
harrison talking about her preparation
being very difficult yeah
that's it
that's him yeah that's him
at the same time you go back and ask
ronda rousey about her career right my
dad was her coach yeah my dad
moved her to camp camp new hampshire in
boston
got her up ran her in the morning had
her downstairs in the basement of his
house training with the weights we
brought a russian girl in she did throws
on his cement outside with the little
crash bag through the russian girl you
know 100 times that morning and then
every night
came to boston you know to the training
center in wakefield trains at night and
went back and slept at my dad's house
and
three weeks straight before she went off
to beijing and he did the same with
kayla he did the same with me like
he's just his passion is is producing
athletes the highest level and he knows
how to do it and then
the one side of my dad's
coaching where i think there's a flora
weakness is on the mental preparation
side of the game he wasn't somebody that
was
um i don't know if he he
maybe because he wasn't an olympic
champion himself and wasn't a world
champion he lacked the confidence in
helping others be more confident so he's
more of a
this is what you need to work on type of
thing he doesn't know how to build the
athletes up to make them feel invincible
and i feel like that's something that i
was able to give all of the athletes to
to help them with that visualization
belief in yourself knowing that you're
going to win before you step out of the
mat knowing that we've earned the right
to victory you know seeing success in
your mind
having a positive uh mantra that you i'm
the best in the world nobody's beating
me today type of type of feeling so you
go out there feeling like king kong when
you step on the mat that nobody's going
to stop you you know and so i think the
combination of both of us as coaches
i'm a
a lot more technical my dad is good at
letting identifying what they need to do
for their techniques and what you know
how in strategy how to beat how to beat
opponents and putting game plans
together
um so combined the two of us made a an
unbelievable team so he uh he's not
going to let the athlete be soft when
they uh when they enter
the highest the most difficult uh uh
competitions of their career
so on the mental side
what's mental preparation look like like
how many years before the olympics
do you start helping an athlete believe
that they can win
an olympic medal
well i think it's got to be a seed in
that athlete's brain something they want
to do right nobody
nobody can quickly get there right it's
a long process but if your goal if
you're a national champion or you've
proven yourself to win it in some
international tournaments
and you think the olympics is a
possibility for you then defining it as
hey i want to be on the olympic team
that would be the first step into
you know into um getting ready and
you know but you i always make them put
it on paper you know if it really is
your goal then you show me that it's
your goal and put it on paper and commit
to it i want to be olympic medalist i
want to be olympic champion i want to go
to the olympics world team member maybe
junior world team member whatever it is
we we walk before we go to the highest
level but
if the goal is to go to the olympics
let's let's accomplish these other
things first right because if we if we
can accomplish these other things
then we're on our way to getting to the
ultimate goal which is the olympics
for somebody like kayla for example you
know she didn't
she didn't
say that she wanted to be olympic
champion you know when she first came
here in 2005. right
we wanted to
become national champion then we wanted
to be on the world team then we wanted
to be a world medalist then we our sites
were set on the olympics or the olympic
gold you know so it's having those
clearly defined goals that are
attainable like they should be a reach
they should be a stretch
but they have to be attainable they
can't be just a pipe dream you know but
once you put it to paper and if you
think it's achievable then it's it's
mapping the plan to get there
is there a daily process of visualizing
yourself as an olympic champion or
national champion yes
it is
you should do it every either every
night before you go to bed
or every
um before every training session or
after every training session one of
those three times it should or first
thing you wake up in the morning because
it may be to help some people it
motivates them to go do what it is they
they're supposed to do in the day
um
but the process of visualization is is
to me
is closing your eyes for
a few moments your brain works really
really fast right and it's actually
picturing the day
in its entirety from start to finish you
know from the moment you wake up and you
step on the scale
so the moment you have your breakfast
and you go through your morning routine
like live the day that you're going to
have at the olympics so whatever it is
you're trying to do let's say the
olympic day for example
picture yourself making weight picture
yourself who you're around eating your
breakfast you know having maybe saying a
few jokes laughing this is a real day
make it real yeah um going back and
getting packing your judo bag for the
day you know getting on the bus
driving to the venue
feel what it's like walking into the
stadium
you know for the first time going to the
warm-up area
seeing your drawer up on the you know on
the sheet who you're going to fight that
day
watching yourself warm up go through
your warm-up routine
walking out of the chute you know into
the venue going to do that first fight
picture the moment of throwing your
opponent coming off the mat high-fiving
the coach
getting ready for your second fight like
live the day
from start to finish and make it as real
as possible
you know where all the way to the moment
where you've just won and you're raising
your arms in celebration you're bowing
you're hugging your opponent you come
off the mat you hug your coach
you're running around the stadium with
the flag
you know you you stepped up on the
podium you heard your name olympic
champion jimmy pedro like you heard the
moment
the the the metal being put around your
neck
picture the people coming up on the
podium with you
arms around them taking the pictures
like
the more real you can make it
even before it ever happens
right
when you do that enough times
i feel that like
pathways get created
for you so that when your your body gets
to that moment
and i've been here before this is it
this is my moment this is what i've
pictured my whole life i'm not nervous
because i've seen this this is gonna
happen i believe it's possible right and
i believe the athletes that do that and
make it real enough
that when they get to that moment
they go right through there's no
hesitation
yeah this is what this is meant to be
this is my destiny this is why i did
everything i did
versus the ones that don't think about
it ever but just kind of like hope yeah
it's not real to them it doesn't feel
attainable they don't believe it's
possible they haven't committed to
believing it was possible without that
commitment in yourself and that belief
it can't happen and one thing that uh i
talked to travis a bit about this
uh you probably worked with him
on the details of what you're talking
about
but he said that you should really
like focus on visualizing like the
sensations
you feel so like say if you're drinking
coffee or something like that
you're not
thinking about like
like observing yourself from a third
person perspective drinking coffee like
you're you're thinking of how your
hand will feel when it touches something
warm like you tried to replay the actual
sensations you would feel right so it
sounds uh kind of strange but meaning
like you really want to put yourself in
the body as you would experience those
moments as opposed to like watching
yourself on tv experience in those
moments like really be inside and yeah
so that means sensations like how does
it feel when you grip a ghee how does it
you know
um the yeah the the sweating just the
sensation of sweat
like rolling down your forehead or
whatever like all of those actual
feelings
when i explain it to you yeah like i
guess my body has been through through
it so many times both in my mind and in
reality that it brings back all of those
same emotions it
i start to get goosebumps my my armpits
start to sweat like i'm living it if
it's real yeah i'm reliving it now but i
in your when you're going through the
visualization process
it has to be that real the the smells
the the the taping of the fingers like
the more colorful and the more real you
can make it
the more believable it is
so i've been doing this kind of thing
just
having listened to you enough
for uh other stuff in life so let's see
if it works
uh but do you see this kind of
visualization being useful for other
things
in career and all those kind of things
all 100
100 because
i just know with my own life my own my
own experiences like i
like my wife sometimes says to me she
says well where do you see yourself in
like you know
five years from now and five years ago
i had said to her you know i want to
have my own business i want to have you
know
this is the amount of money that i'm
hoping i can make in a given year like
you have to have goals for yourself like
is this if you put out there like okay i
want to make a million dollars in a year
that's a big number like like for me or
for the normal person that like that's a
really big number you know what i mean
like it's not especially when you're not
making that much at the time it's a
super big number right so having those
goals for yourself like
it it won't happen and it's not possible
unless you dream
it's possible and think it that it's
possible and then it doesn't magically
happen and maybe it doesn't happen in
five years maybe happens in 10 at least
you're on the path to getting there
you know what i mean and i said i want
to own my own business i want to control
my own destiny i want to be my own boss
i want to make my own decisions like
these are the things that i told her i
wanted to do and and now
i'm at that point
you know where you know i work for
myself i have my own company i have
partners obviously but like
if i want to pick up and go somewhere
for a week i just do i have to ask
permission to do it right that that's
what life freedom right that's what i
like yeah it's so and all of it starts
with a dream
in in the same with my dojo when i first
opened
so i ran a dojo for a long time and i
only had 60 students always like 40 to
60 students had fluctuated
and i sit there and say why can't i get
more people in my door right so i hired
consultants to come in and look at my
business and say why right and
they came in and said well this place is
really intimidating like if i was coming
in off the street the first thing i see
is this big olympic champion on the wall
and i see this training that's going on
and these guys are flying through the
air and landing hard and as a white belt
you're telling me that's the class for
me like no way i'm not going to do that
so like i listened to these people i
said you're right
and you know the training was hour and a
half two hours long people can't handle
an hour and a half or two hours training
when i first walked in the door so i had
to restructure all my programming
i had to look at the way i was offering
my my curriculum at my school and i had
to make
levels for everybody right like
here's my four to six year old class
here's my six to 13 year old class
there's my all my beginner classes they
don't mix in with the advanced people
and like
you know and i had to learn how to
make it accessible for everybody instead
of just the the people that wanted to
train hard and
then the challenge was okay if you can
have a lot of people in your dojo
training
it's a recreational school you can't
produce champions at that same school
that's what i was told
so then i got all my black belts
together and i said listen this is my
vision this is what i want i want to
have a club that has over 200 judo only
athletes no jiu jitsu no karate nothing
judo only i want over 200 people
and in the inside of that dojo i want to
have olympic champions and i want to
have recreational like little kids five
and six years old older guys in their
70s training i don't care but i want the
spectrum of recreational and i want
olympic champions the only way to do
that is
to take your instructors and say you're
going to do this define the roles who's
going to be the recreational coach who's
going to be the competitive coach how do
we separate these programs
and lo and behold that was my vision
that i shared with all of them and that
was back in
2006
and by
2012 we've got olympic champion kayla
harrison we have over 200 people at the
school we have a successful thriving
business but it doesn't happen without
that vision
a plan
and believing that
it's possible believing that it's
possible
i don't know but i personally have uh
on top of that
almost like very specific visions of of
a future like uh um
i don't know what an because i don't
want to give actual examples
because uh for several reasons
one of which is just people will
as they often have they often will in
your life they'll just uh
laugh at it a little bit like that seems
silly
and i don't i'm very hesitant to share
certain things like that with people
because they'll
i mean um i'm with johnny ive
who's the lead designer in apple like
you want that dream that little flame to
not people will put that flame out too
easily even people that love you
so i have very specific kind of
visions like well maybe for travis it
would be like
a specific opponent or something like
holy bishop like very specific
very specific situation of what's going
to happen not just like i want to be
olympic champion but very specific like
almost silly situations
yeah like the dynamic between travis and
ollie bishop or something like maybe
visualize that for me that helps because
it makes it all real even more real it's
not like some big goal like a million
dollars or something like that
which is also really important to have
because you can measure it and so on but
the
it's it's just like you belong in those
situations
just believing you belong right right
right in there it's not that they could
be you yeah it could be you and that for
some reason that really helps me the the
little details sure the like visualizing
is
most of them are almost a little bit
funny
like the the focusing on the funniness
it's the the mundaneness of it
uh helps me a lot and all the people
that have done great things they're just
human too
correct and i think a lot of people
overestimate who others are right and
don't
and and sell themselves too short yeah
because at the end of the day everybody
started
like everybody else really i mean we did
you know we were all infants we couldn't
walk we couldn't talk we couldn't do
anything we learned along the way but
and i think that's the one thing that i
realized is that
and i tell this to to my athletes but i
also tell it to my recreational students
nobody is better than you are nobody
unless you allow them to be
right if you really want something to
happen then like map the plan
believe in yourself decide and no
full out you're going to fail a lot
you're going to get beat down you're
going to have losses you're going to
have struggles like and i think that's
the one thing with social media today is
that
everybody sees everybody succeed nobody
posts the picture when they're on the
ground in failure losing like nobody
nobody sees when you broke your arm and
you had to go through rehab you know
whatever it is like had your injuries
and you're on your couch watching tv and
you were suffering and you were like
everybody has really really dark bad
moments in their life and defeats and
losses and suffrage
and
it's only at the end after they've
recovered from all of that they've
reclined up the mountain and they've
gone to the pinnacle that you see them
on social media with the metal
right but everybody else
like struggles and was human and
failed many many times and
you know
convincing yourself that you're capable
i think is the first start with
everything do you need people in your
life that
believe in you or should
most of it come from within yourself
i think most of it has to come in from
from it it certainly helps but it has to
come from you
first you have to be driven like other
people can help you
define where you want to go and help you
get there and encourage you and can
support you and you know whether it's
resource wise or with connections and
like they can help with that path but
that that first part has to come from
you it has to be your passion your
desire your
it's your commitment to yourself you're
the one that's going to ultimately make
all the sacrifices to do it so you ha it
has to be your decision not your parents
not your spouse's something that you're
really motivated to do
let me ask you about travis kayla and
maybe a few of the other athletes you've
been involved with so first travis
travis stevens
olympic silver medalist
three-time olympian
2008 2012 2016.
what makes travis stevens great what
makes him so successful what makes him
unique in your mind as an athlete
through all the hardship he had to
overcome
[Music]
through his uh weird looking say inagi
that uh eventually worked out nicely
to the the full richness of his
personality in the context of all the
other great athletes you've coached what
makes him special
his fight
travis has fight and you know the first
time i ever saw travis stevens was in
like recognized him maybe i had seen him
before as a younger boy or something but
like actually recognized him as
i brought a group of young kids to italy
for a competition in a training camp and
it was this program called u23 elite and
i picked hand-picked 20 kids
to go to this event and it was the first
time i coached uh an international team
and i had never seen travis fight before
compete train anything and during this
competition
you know he's an 81 kilo player i think
he was maybe like 18 years old um
17 18 years old and
it was a really hard european event and
i think travis won three matches and he
lost two
but what stood out the most to me was
like
the fight he had in him
he was scrapping every fight like he
scrapped hard like he wanted to win more
than any of them right he didn't win but
he wanted to win more and i and i
noticed that right away and then i also
noticed that after he lost his second
match and he was eliminated from the
tournament i saw how disappointed he was
in himself
like he actually thought he was supposed
to beat those people even though he was
like 17
right he's fighting against grown men
that are you know a high level judo much
higher than he was and i said to him i
said hey son like
don't worry man you got a long career
ahead of you like i'm glad you're
disappointed but there's so many things
you don't know and so many skills you
don't have the fact that you were able
to hold your own and scrap like that
like you've got a good future and i
remember calling my friend jason morris
after that tournament and i said hey man
do you ever hear this kid travis stevens
he says no why i said man that kid's got
some fighting him right and i said that
i said that to jason at the time i said
that kid's got some fight in him man
he's pretty talented you know and that's
how it started
um
but so i saw that i meant when he was
young but the other thing was
travis like there's not there's no such
thing as hard work to that guy
if you tell him to put his head through
the wall and help and that's how he wins
he'll go put his head through the wall
he'll do whatever it takes
for him to do
to achieve success
and he hates
failure
more than he likes winning 100
he always has he punishes himself when
he doesn't do well he makes himself work
harder he goes and you know
just
abuses himself when he doesn't when he
doesn't succeed because he's so
heartbroken and disappointed in himself
so
that's a trait that i think all of the
athletes that i work with
like closely though they all had that
same trait they hated losing more than
anything they would they would break
their arm they'd fall on their head you
know they'd rather get hit by a car than
lose a judo tournament yeah you know and
then and as a result then they all had
fight and they all were willing to train
they were willing to listen and they
would do anything for victory you know
within you know within the rules i'm not
talking about taking drugs or anything
like that but they would
they'd give a hundred percent of
themselves
for victory and
you know travis was somebody that when
he was down he found a way to do to get
better doing something else if he
couldn't do standing that's when he
started jiu jitsu he couldn't go on his
feet anymore he couldn't stand up and
train i might as well go learn jiu jitsu
and get good on the ground right because
i can you know so he always found a way
no matter what obstacle was in his way
he just went around it
so what about the
interesting to get your perspective
because i know travis's perspective is
the
just the number of injuries
like what do you make of the
perseverance through all the injuries he
had to overcome specifically like you
just observing this creature that you've
coached
i mean he seems to not see the injuries
as a problem he's just like just like
you said head through the wall it's like
what like when i when we were talking
about injuries
he kind of he doesn't even see the
injuries themselves as the problem
because he thinks that the injuries you
know you heal back stronger
i forget the exact quote but he said
like
my body is is now less injury prone than
most of
anyone else because i've already broken
i've broken everything and it's just
growing back stronger
like because i asked them something like
do you regret sort of pushing your body
to
all of those places that resulted in
those injuries
he was his response was like no i'm
stronger now
so i don't know if that's justification
but that certainly describes a mindset
that yeah head through the wall
that doesn't uh it's almost not
dramatic like look i got this injury
it's so i'm so like brave and special
for overcoming this injury he's just
he's just that's part of the job and he
gets the job done
but like that job evolves a lot of
injuries one of the talks i gave travis
and that team at that at that particular
tournament was at the very beginning of
the camp after the tournament i said to
them listen
my vision i shared my vision with them i
said my vision is
you know in seven years because that was
2005. i said in seven years i want to
have a u.s team
that steps on the mat that is ready to
kick ass
and in order to get there all of you
guys can be a part of this team and part
of this process but in order to get
there you guys have to be the first ones
to practice you have to be the last ones
to leave because we have to work harder
than the rest of the world because we're
up against all odds i said i am sick of
america being a laughing stock of judo
and being the first round easy match
warm-up for everybody else
i said if you get injured you're not
going to be on the side with with you
know with a ice bag on taking off rounds
and then get back on the mat the next
day and tell me you're okay if you can
train the next day you can train today
so there's no injury the only time
you're leaving this dojo is if the
ambulance has to take you out of here
you know i and i do think subliminally
travis bought into that message and
heard that message then he said if i'm
going to be a champion that's the way
i'm going to do it and he did and he
embodied it he lived it man there were
many times in europe where i said dude
just tape it up go go off to the side
just take the day off like take the rest
of the day off you're beat up you can't
do it he says no i'm going to tape it up
i'm going to tell you no
you don't need to right now and he said
no sensei i'm doing it i'm you know
the ambulance isn't taking me out it's
just just my wrist it's just my ankle
it's just my it's just my ankle you know
i love it
yeah what about the so the other really
big thing is you comment on a little bit
is the weight cut
so early in his career he was 81 kg
and that was presumably not so difficult
but later in his career
his 81 kg and it's becoming more and
more difficult so
that's that's the other thing with him
is uh so i've known a lot of
really really tough people at the
highest levels broken by the weight cut
like that can break the toughest minds
and it doesn't seem to have broken him
and he's delivered on it often
on like insane way cuts
so um
just as a coach what do you think about
his particular his mind and the
challenge of the way cut
it was part of his process it was part
of his way of getting ready for battle
suffering yeah it really was and if i'm
going to suffer this much then i'm going
to make my opponents pay yeah for all
the suffering that i went through to get
here yeah that was his mindset
um
later on in his career you're right like
a lot of times travis he would never
step on a scale
you know until he got to the tournament
you know and even when he'd get to the
tournament
like he'd weigh like 90 kilos he'd show
up at the tournament nine kilos over
i'm like you have to but i never it was
just an expectation of making weight
not making weight was never an option
for any of our athletes and travis knew
it and he said
as a professional my job is to make
weight if i don't make weight he you
know he he was never going to allow that
to happen and he was never going to
allow us to come to him and say hey
i told you you know because he
losing wasn't an option making a weight
wasn't not making weight was not an
option for him ever either but you know
a lot of times he wouldn't even
he'd be nine kilos over on the plane
going over to the tournament and have to
make weight three days later you know
and he didn't break 86 kilos
until the day before the tournament like
he had five kilos over the day before
that was his way but he would do
three workouts you know wake up in the
morning work out then he'd eat then he'd
work out in the afternoon then he'd eat
again then he'd work out again at night
and then he'd reward himself hey i
worked out three times today he'd go
have a you know a mountain dew yeah you
know or chocolate bar you know and then
he's next morning he's uh you know back
up to 87 and he would never touch weight
until the morning of lance that that's a
when he that he wasn't on weight for
more than like five minutes
his process would break a lot of people
so the fact that he got the job done is
not just the job done but every single
time he got the job done and i made
those athletes fight
we would fight in paris we would do a
camp for a week double session camp for
a week
he'd be seven kilos over have to fight
the next weekend
we're talking two or three days later
you know so not only did he make the
weight but he did a grueling training
camp twice a day and and then cut weight
and then fought again then did another
camp for a week in double session
training camp and then fought on the
third weekend in a row and our athletes
went through hell you know all of our
athletes went through hell because on
the tour
around the world they fought in every
event they did every camp they fought in
every event
whereas most of the other teams like
japan comes in and fights in paris then
they go home you know they maybe do a
camp for three days then they go home
they don't stay in europe for four or
five weeks straight and fighting every
tournament and when you get to germany
the germans skip the french open they
skip the camp in france they're just
getting ready for germany our athletes
already had two competitions two
training camps
two three weight cuts now and then so
they're not a hundred percent when they
fight in germany but that's all part of
the experience they need the training
that they need that they don't get here
in the in in this country and all of
those were just preparation for our
world championships or our olympic games
so by the time our athletes got to those
tournaments
they felt so strong so rested so like
man this guy
that felt like a monster in germany
feels like nothing today
because you're fully rested now you know
but part of the challenge is because the
american team is smaller
and more i mean just smaller
is um
you know all the different places you go
for to do the weight cut to do the diet
to do the preparation or the recovery
there's like that process changes
every time
so it's you're basically have to
improvise a lot oh yeah you show up to a
hotel
and how you do the weight cut you don't
know and this is the different weather
conditions it's not
it's like um
so what is it rocky versus drago right
right right so you don't have you have
to just improvise and that that's also a
fascinating part of the american judo
story which is like you have to
improvise more well
i was funny because when i it was 1990
and it was at the goodwill games
right and we were it was a u.s olympic
committee type event and so we're on the
bus with the the swim team
and it was me and jason morris on the
american team and we're going to the
judo competition but we're on the bus
with the swim team i'm sorry we're going
to the venue where we're staying you
know i remember being like by ourselves
with no staff no no no manager no coach
we'll just buy ourselves going to fight
in russia right and uh
and the swim team's on there with their
full sweats and their staff and like
their managers and i i heard the lady
the girl go
oh sorry this is 1994 because it was in
st petersburg russia so
i heard the little girl on the team she
goes up the coast she goes coach um
do you think you can send the massage
therapist to my room at 10 a.m you know
i'm feeling kind of jet-lagged
i looked it i mean jason
we looked at it like
she
yeah wouldn't even have a staff like
what the hell is going on here you know
what a difference in yeah sporting you
know different sports within the same
country
you know and but that i mean not to
romanticize things but that you do
represent the spirit of the olympics
when you're kind of
the the
improvisational nature of it because it
it is just you you and sometimes you and
the coach and just
pure guts and
you against the world with no money the
warrior spirit the warrior spirit
how did it feel like when he after
being in two olympics beating some of
the best people in the world
facing some of the best people in the
world and
just barely losing
what did it feel like to you as a coach
to see travis stevens win the silver
medal
electric
uh like
first of all in
2012 in london
it was like it it felt like somebody
died i'm not gonna be i'm not gonna lie
to you like the ole bishop match not no
just seeing travis not finish on the
podium period
you know
in the only bishop match i thought he
won regardless of who won and who lost
he just left everything he had on that
mat right 10 minutes of
probably a 20-something minute match but
10 minutes of fighting actually right
he left everything he had he wanted to
be in the olympic finals he wanted to be
olympic champion and when he didn't get
that opportunity he lost everything he
he drained himself he cried for 45
minutes straight
i couldn't regroup them i couldn't get
them up i said travis you've got to stop
you're crying you've got to get off the
floor we've got a bronze medal fight
like
if you don't recover you're not going to
perform well and he just didn't care
like it was gold or nothing and so when
he walked out against the canadian boy
he had beaten the canadian i think at
that time he had beaten that canadian
every single time except for that bronze
medal match but he just didn't have the
fight in him anymore he left it all in
the match in the bishop match so to see
him come back with zero right we just
had a team where
his best friend marty malloy won a
bronze medal
right
then the day after travis fights kayla
harrison goes and wins her first gold
medal right our first ever goal so we
have a gold and a bronze he's his
training partner wins a gold his best
friend from growing up wins a bronze he
has nothing
right to see him for four years
go through hell like literally like all
of his injuries every training camp and
then forget the humiliation because
every time any reporter ever came to my
dojo they want to talk to kayla she's
the olympic champion yeah who's this
travis guy yeah you know who is this guy
you know so
he didn't meddle you know he's not that
important and you know up until right
until you get to the right before the
olympics now they talk about he's an
olympian again and yeah but up until
that point and then every little kid
see kayla's medal oh travis yeah you
went to the olympics where's your medal
how did you do you know it was i took
fifth i didn't place you know it's it's
the lowest of low every day having that
constant reminder
so
four years later
when that guy i mean
mentally he was ready
physically
he was ready that was the best and
strongest travis stevens
that i've ever seen and i've ever felt
because i had to get on the mat and do
some drills and stuff like that and like
try to defend on bars and because we
didn't have a lot of bodies in in rio
and i was like my god he's
i said after one of the practices was
the strongest i've ever felt that guy
right before the competition so
physically was ready
mentally the morning of competition i
said to travis i i looked him in the eye
and i said you know we're ready to go
over to the venue i said are you ready
today and he just looked at me like he
goes
i am going to shock the world today
i'm going to shock the world today and i
said all right great let's go right so
we go to the venue
and um
every other athlete was just
like nervously like doing repetitions of
uchi comeys you could see like sweat
coming out you could see like all this
nervous energy going through their body
and here comes travis stevens he's got
these big goofy headphones on
he's got a tank top that says usa on it
he's got the swim trunks that say usa
like that have shiny letters that glow
in the dark yeah and and he's like and
this is in the middle of the judo hall
where all these athletes are warming up
for their first match
he's like dancing around like doing this
loose warm-up like almost like
a little kid at an amusement park whose
dad said yeah go play you know
and it was like he had waited four years
for that moment he was so relaxed yeah
so focused so relaxed and couldn't wait
it was like a cage tiger like if you
like coming out of the chute to go step
on to the the mat
was like this tiger that you were just
letting out of the cage and he just go
like now is your time to go fight and
that's what he did that whole day and
like
when he beat turkish villain in the in
the semis and choked them out and won
that fight
like there's nobody with the exception
of maybe
the guys in the america team there was
nobody in that stadium that expected
travis to beat him yeah nobody yeah like
you know he had smashed travis i don't
know how many times before that free
phone like in the first minute even it
wasn't even a fight right and and
it was great game plan he's the world
number one at the time too
world number one at the time uh world
champion
carried the flag for the georgian
federation walking into the games
uh
most dominant 90 81 kilo player in that
weight class for you know quite some
time and
man we just had his number and travis
was ready to go you know it was so cool
it was so awesome we were i mean we had
already won kayla had already won her
second goal
right the way the the
the event went and
travis winning that was like icing on
the cake for our team that was the best
performance we've ever had in history
it's awesome so you mentioned kayla
she is
one of if not the greatest american
judoka ever
uh two-time gold medalist
2010 world champion 2010 first senior
worlds senior worlds
what makes
kayla special what makes her so great
what made this champion
it's a combination of of
a lot of things
one was obviously kayla's mental
toughness right to overcome what she
overcame
you know this is a girl who
you know let
let's i don't say forget about the
sexual abuse but the the fact that she
had to go through that in life and and
learned how to compartmentalize that and
keep that off as a separate part of her
brain you know and forget about it and
move on
that took an incredible team to help her
do that and my dad was a huge part of
her accomplishing that so for people who
don't know we should comment and say
that kayla had to go through trauma
in her earlier life
through sexual abuse and had to overcome
that through the whole process of
of becoming a champion as well right
because she had zero self-esteem zero
self-worth she was the lowest of lows
and and
um
you know didn't even want to be on this
earth right so she she was
traumatized obviously for
and getting her the right help and
surrounding her with the right people
who could help her
get through that and and be by her side
as she's getting through that and
letting her know and reaffirming that
she's doing the right thing and she made
the right decision and she should have
zero guilt and
you know this doesn't define her it
happened to her but it doesn't define
her what defines her is what she does
from now on and then rebuilding that
person to become who she became i think
the mental toughness is is a big part of
it her her mind um
but then
as an athlete
you know she's a lot like travis
you know she's she's a warrior she's a
fighter you know my dad always jokes
with her you know
he says you're a workhorse you're not a
thoroughbred we're not going to treat
you like a thoroughbred right you're a
workhorse so you're going to work and
the way you're going to get bigger and
stronger is you're going to work harder
and you're going to keep you know and
she came to us when she was only 15. so
at that time we got her with a really
good strength and conditioning coach we
did all the core olympic style lifting
like as her body was developing
she was getting stronger every single
day and then you know she had the luxury
of being on the mat with
at the time i was still young enough to
train and be on the mat and i was around
her weight class and travis was able to
train with her and all we had all the
top u.s athletes at the time
training here at my school so she got
the benefit of all the best guys to
train within the country
you know and and her doing all of those
rounds
you know night in week
night every night every week every year
compiled with the best you know highest
level she could as a girl
she got the strength she got the
technique she got the and then she had
the coaching on top of it with my dad
being on her as you know working her out
and you know having the
the wherewithal to develop a strategy
and a plan for her because when she
first came here
she competed at 63 kilos which is 138
pounds
at the time
ronda was ronda rousey was also training
here and she was 70 kilos
so if kayla was struggling making 63 so
the only way to obviously the only way
to still compete is to move up but my
dad said well if you move up then you're
in rhonda's weight so let's skip that
weight and you're going to go to 78
kilos and he told her listen you're
gonna go up two eight classes
she looked at him and was like that's
172 pounds and he goes well i don't care
like you're already struggling making
138 you weigh 150 what's the difference
we put 20 pounds on go to 170. so that's
why she jumped two weights because she
passed rhonda
she went to the weight above so she
could make the national team and she had
a chance to go to the olympics and and
all that because we envisioned ronda
staying around until 2012. and that's
also like a long-term vision because you
kind of grow into that body then over
time correct so you can dominate you can
learn what it's like in that weight
class you can learn to dominate that
weight classic excel and then dominate
people that cut weight too hard too long
they forget about technique because
they're only worried about losing weight
they're always tired in training they
don't give 100 effort they're not
getting better she now is just focused
on getting better at judo you know and
getting bigger getting stronger getting
more powerful so i think giving her that
purpose and that that was a great call
what are some memorable or maybe the
most memorable moment kayla harrison
moment to you as her coach
not the most perhaps let's say
what are some memorable moments
everybody hears the good ones right so
everybody knows she won the war she won
the world championships in tokyo in 2012
in 2010 she was our two-time olympic
champion in 2012 2016. i'll never forget
those moments right because they're
historic
one of the
biggest moments that i like sharing this
story with everybody is that
in 2010 in january
kayla was still a developing athlete and
we had a local tournament in new york
it was in brooklyn new york was called
the starrett cup
and i knew that at that tournament that
two of the canadian girls they were like
ranked 15th or 20th in the world they
weren't superstars but they were tough
players
both of them i knew were going to be at
that tournament so i said kayla we're
going to go to this tournament you're
going to compete against the canadian
girls get some good experience you know
figure out what you need to work on and
then we'll go home and work on some
stuff
well she went to the tournament there
was only three girls in the weight her
and the two canadians
at that tournament
she lost both fights
right so this is january 2010.
she lost both matches you know she was
competitive but certainly things she
needed to work on it was good you know
development thing for her and for us it
also opened her mind to say oh man you
know because she was already a
a junior world champion
at the time but so now there's another
level this is a senior level right you
got to go up another level and here's
two girls that aren't even medalists
that are beating you so now there's more
work to be done
and so i like telling that story because
everybody sees the champions and the
greatest moments they don't see them
when they have bad days and could you
imagine being you know oh and two
you feel like you feel like a failure
right
but
ten months later
it was tokyo 2010. she went from owen to
at starrett new york
to world champion 2010 in the motherland
in japan yeah
i mean that's an amazing turnaround
and that's only possible if you
put the losses in their proper context
you don't let it destroy you mentally
you just keep moving forward correct
this is so funny uh so you were there
2010 at the stair cup was travis there
yeah i made all those we fought at every
loc like the mentality of our team was
no tournament is beneath us
if our goal is to go to the olympics in
the worlds and win
there's no tournament that's beneath us
we're going to get experience we're
going to fight we're going to learn
we're going to compete we're going to
get better
you know
i actually just as a funny little con
side i was there i competed really this
is one of the earlier tournaments like
the beginner division oh no i actually
did black belt division too
that was one of the actual yeah i
remember that
that's when it was so early that i
thought
like i was also really strong at that
time just like physically like
powerlifting stuff so i thought like it
would be good experience
uh to also do uh black belt division and
remember
it must have been actually travis's
division which is funny uh
uh there's legere brothers
harry and gary they are super they're
super good and they're super dominant
but i think travis faced one of them
and beat them
um i i don't know i just remembered uh
it's funny how there's just like these
little roads that later
reconnect right uh but yeah there's some
incredible people there
and it i saw obviously the positive
things and it's interesting that kayla's
story was also intersecting there and
that was one of the lower points for her
another story i like to to share is that
you have to know your athletes right and
you have to you know really get to know
their psychological what they're
thinking psychologically mentally what's
going through their head another
story was in in tokyo it was
2015
the tokyo grand slam
so we had
had kayla face off against almost all
the top girls in her in her division she
had beaten everybody going into the 2016
olympics but at the 2015
tokyo grand slam
there was a girl from japan
that she hadn't fought in a long time
and she lost to the girl last time she
she fought her so it was something we
wanted her to beat this girl going into
the olympics so that she knew she could
beat everybody
and it was a first-round match
and
it was gonna be tough for kayla right it
was gonna be a really hard fight and
um she had won a bunch of tournaments in
a row leading up to that so her
confidence was really high but at the
same time
she didn't think she needed this fight
and she showed up to the tournament and
she said
i don't think i can fight today i've got
a stinger in my neck you know i've got a
stinger coming down my neck and i'm kind
of sore and
she didn't tell us she went and told the
trainer she walked around she's holding
her neck and me and my dad were like
what's up with her i don't know
and then so
like maybe she doesn't want to fight
today i don't know right so
all of a sudden the trainer comes up to
us and she didn't come to us the trainer
came to us you know i really don't think
it's a good idea that kayla fight today
i mean we looked at him and like
well your opinion doesn't really matter
does it okay
what's up with her yeah oh she has this
thing in her neck it's like a pinched
nerve and there's this and then
we talked i said
is there a risk of her getting injured
like is this pain or is this risk that
she's going to get injured and she's
going to set her back like long time in
her career
she says no she's not going to get
injured it's just a pinched nerve a
little pain she's going to have to deal
with like okay well can you fix the pain
he says yeah i can do this and that and
i can give her a shot and the pain will
go away
okay then do that
and so kayla kayla comes up she goes
didn't the trainer talk to you he said
yeah he talked to us well he said i
can't fight
i know but we already talked to the
trainer and
i love it he said you're good to go yeah
she looked at us like
and then we had to talk to her and say
listen
you're not injured you're in pain
because we just came from a camp i said
you're in pain but here's the deal we
want you to fight this girl why don't
you go out there and beat this girl
period i don't care i want to know that
you can beat this girl this is why we
came this is our last hard tournament
before the olympic games
this is what you what we want from you
and lo and behold she understood she
they gave her a quick shot the rest of
the world thought we were crazy making
her compete yeah and then she went out
there
she fought
didn't even know she was injured no you
know what i mean she just went out there
she fought the tournament she beat the
japanese girl she ended up going through
the whole tournament she took a gold
medal
she won the event
it turned out to be a great confidence
builder and
it it yeah
uh and that kind of sets you up for all
the chaos that can happen at the olympic
games and it tells you if you can beat
these girls when you're not 100 yeah and
you're not at your best you're
physically beat mentally beat
imagine what you're going to do when
you're fresh well when she was going to
the olympic games there's a lot she had
the mental game
down down down there wasn't a girl in
that division that thought that could be
kayla going into those games not a one
they just looked at her and went no not
happening yeah
that's great i mean she's a great
olympic champion two-time olympic
champion but there is uh
there is something that she's commented
on which is
she's suffered or
went through depression after winning
her second olympic gold
why do you think this happens
you often hear stories of great
champions
becoming depressed after the olympics
there's a lack of purpose afterwards
right because you've done
in life what you set out to do you've
had a goal every day you woke up you
knew what your purpose was you knew what
your you know what your day looked like
you knew why you were doing that and all
of a sudden you won and you got all the
fame and you're all happy and it
but then you wake up and you go
now what i don't have a next and and
also because there was nothing for her
there was no
there was no path set out for kayla that
said okay we're gonna you know you're
gonna become an ambassador a global
ambassador of judo
you know the ijf is going to help pay a
salary the the usa judo is going to give
you a salary here's what we want you to
go teach children we want you to go be
an ambassador for women we're going to
fly around and you know whatever it is
we're going to give you a job and here's
what you're going to do you know if
you'd like to take it there was nothing
for her like i remember doing the
interview at the olympics with her
and they said are you going to compete
in the next olympics and i said no like
why she already two-time gold medalist
what does three-time gold medalist do
for her nothing right it doesn't
motivate her to do it again
they said are you doing mma i said no
why would she do on me that's ridiculous
like she doesn't need mma she should be
able to make a living off of what she's
accomplished in this sport for the rest
of her life yes but what happens is and
what most people don't understand is
once you say i'm retired i'm no longer
competing in the in the sport of judo
you don't get a salary from usa judo
anymore which she was getting
i think she got like 72 000 a year from
from usa judo at the time
you don't get
a stipend from the olympic committee
anymore goes away
your sponsor like the new york athletic
club was a great sponsor for her for all
those years in fact she could have never
been the athlete she became without the
support of the nyc because i talked to
them when she was 15 i said hey i got a
girl that's really good
someday like if you invest in her now
i promise you she'll pay back for you
and they said and i remember the day she
won the olympic gold i called the guy up
and said hey i told you
so but you know they can no longer give
you stipends because you're not
competing and representing them anymore
so that goes away
um all of your sponsorships and all of
your money that you would make from your
tv commercials or whatever that didn't
happen for her after the olympics
because judo is an obscure sport right
so she didn't have any opportunities for
that
at the end of the day she has no no
revenue coming in how do you live you
get a bonus of 25 grand from the olympic
committee or whatever for for winning a
gold but aside from that you're not
going to live on that money so no
purpose no goal right what am i going to
wake up and do tomorrow i don't know so
she has no direction and at the same
then at the same time she has no money
coming in
so everything shuts off so now it's like
where do you turn what do you do
you know and that leads to
being depressed because yeah even though
i've accomplished all this stuff
i'm kind of lost in life like what's
next for me
and i guess you just have to ride that
out because
when you're a great human being great
champion
life has a way of
helping you find a way right i mean she
she's in mixed martial arts now but she
has a lot of stuff going on right
well her kids she she adopted her her
sister's kids so she's their legal
guardian now so that is her purpose
right raising raising these kids and
making them part of her family and
um she's fortunate enough that she has
enough money that she can do that and
she can give them a good life you know
i'm going to ask you to start some
trouble but i heard that she said
somewhere that she can beat khabib
nurmagomedov in judo
what do you think
to be honest with you i mean i don't
know what level of judoka yeah i don't
know i don't know what level he's but i
do know that
that russian system respects judo
immensely what i will tell you is this
i trained with kayla and i was an
olympic medalist and a world champion in
judo
and granted i was older when i trained
with her but you have to go as a man you
have to go 100
or she will smash you yeah as a man and
i could tell you that if khabib
doesn't do a lot of just judo it doesn't
like you know
gripping and doesn't understand like if
he's you know if he can throw that's one
thing
but if he doesn't really understand you
at a high level
she will throw him she would beat him in
a match in a judo contest not in a mixed
martial arts contest not in a wrestling
contest not in a submission contest in a
pure judo match where he cannot grab
legs
and he has to grip up and just throw
i'd put my money on kayla
unless he's you know and if he could go
placed in the nationals in russia he
would beat her but if he's not at that
level of judo he's more like a brown
belt or he's not
he's not a high level judo player she
will win i saw her
take some of our best juniors in this
country
some of the some of the um
guys that went and won our meddled in
our senior nationals
i've seen her smash all of them in judo
now she's not going to do that to a
travis stevens she's not going to do
that you know to a
to a senior national champion you know
or olympian in our sport but she will go
toe-to-toe with
every other male if black belts are not
speaking of khabib and russia um
vladimir putin
i don't know if you have heard of him
he's the president of russia but he's
also judoka yes have you gotten a chance
to uh see him do judo what do you think
about his judo if you were to and so i
i'm actually really good friends with
the the russian federation uh
the the guy in charge is izio gamba he's
an italian he's a mastermind behind
their success of the 2012 and 2016
olympic teams
2020 he suffered from leukemia blood
cancer so he wasn't part of their 2020
program but he was part of 2012 2016.
that whole national the olympic team in
2012 came to our studio
and lived here for a month in boston
they went to school in boston i brought
them to my house they had three olympic
champions
um
they oh my god
they all came and lived here in boston
for a month they wanted to be part of
like experience america type program so
i've seen all of them with putin in
russia
at their national training center
working out with them and taking falls
and doing judo with him so
um you know it's hard when you're older
to move in judo i mean i was at a high
level and i'm you know now 51.
it's hard for me to move like i used to
so at his age he's got to be what 60
between 62 65-ish
i mean it moves really well for somebody
that's that age
you know and probably hasn't done very
much judo for the last however many
years right so that tells you he at one
point he had to be a really good year
player yeah he put in a lot of work at
some point to develop the technique you
can tell when a great judo player even
if they haven't practiced it
even if they're up there in age
like just the way they move right the
way they're going for sayanagi the way
they go for a particular throw the way
they do foot sweeps and all that kind of
stuff you could just tell he's uh he's
good at judo and that's kind of
fascinating
um
it's fascinating to see political
leaders i've gotten to interact with
quite a few
for whom judo was a formative experience
in their life
and that's so interesting that for a lot
of people judo was played a big part in
their life early development it's
similar to like uh if you served in the
military
there's just something about judo it's
the um as a martial art it's not just
the technique so yes
there's something about gaining
confidence through becoming aware of
what like your body can do
the sort of uh the artistry and the
skill of it
also the power being able to dominate
another human being with technique but
also like the um
i don't know the formality the
discipline of just
uh honoring the tradition of it so all
of that mixed together somehow creates
memories it creates memories that kind
of define you as a human being and you
carry that forward throughout your life
and i've just been surprised to know how
many powerful people internationally
have
uh
like in their heart in their who they
are judo for sure
it makes you the human being that you
are it really does like it it becomes a
fabric of if peop the people that stick
with it right that stay with it and it
because it
i i mean it teaches you so many lessons
it's so memorable because of what you
talked about the tradition
um but it's also
you grow with other people you know and
you learn from other people and you
experience things with other people it's
it's such a hands-on sport
that um
it's very memorable and
people love it so much like
right now at my dojo we have like four
generations like somebody that judo with
my dad
you know had a kid who who trained with
me who loved you know judo so much had a
kid that kid was you know now in his 20s
who
did judo and now has a kid who's two or
three or four that's coming to my
toddler program at my school like we're
talking four generations and they all
loved the experience so much and what it
did for them in their lives that they
wanted the next generation to also
experience the same thing
this is a tricky question but if if
people are interested in judo and want
to start learning it in the united
states there's
thousands of jiu-jitsu schools for
example is there advice you can give
to people interested in judo
or
maybe to jiu jitsu
uh
gym owners like how how how do you get
judo as part of your life
in america well i'm if you're fortunate
to live near another dojo right a place
that has judo locally then that's your
best opportunity to learn is to go learn
from another school um unfor
unfortunately
sometimes the nearest dojo might not be
for two hours or three hours away from
where you're at which is
an obstacle you're not going to do that
so
i mean travis and i did start the
american judo system online
it's at
usajudo.com
and we've broken down every single judo
technique
to the very very basic elements of just
movement so we teach every technique of
how you do it mechanically with just
your feet then how you incorporate your
hands and your feet together
how you do it in all directions moving
forward sideways backwards how to then
introduce a partner into the into the
movement
how to do basic
uchi komi or repetitions with a partner
then moving with a partner then how to
throw your opponent static how to throw
your opponent so basically from the very
foundation of the movement all the way
to the most advanced level
we've documented this uh through
separate videos
and we've taken now i think 12 to 15 of
standing techniques combined with a
whole bunch of groundwork techniques and
our goal is just to continue to build
this platform out so that anybody
anywhere can learn online
and can ask questions we have a live
training class every couple weeks every
two weeks he or i answer questions
online
for our our members
ideally what we'd like to do is have a
standing curriculum for jiu jitsu
instructors that want to learn
and become black belts in judo here's
how these are the techniques you need to
know this is how many reps you need to
do this is how efficient you need to get
at that at those techniques to become
certified as an instructor or become a
black belt
and eventually have an online promotion
system where anybody anywhere can just
submit videos
and
show us that they can do those
techniques and obviously we'll have
people review them and
this is a dream and a vision but we've
already started the platform
we're about to do a collaborative effort
with usa judo where all of their members
will start to get access to this
platform as well and if we can get that
uh influx of of money and people on the
platform it'll allow us to
to hire and grow it faster
so you also want to do like
certification
there it's not just instruction correct
that would be amazing yeah um i mean for
me personally sort of i mean mostly in
austin texas now right and there's a few
judo schools but
it's not not really
right there's not uh and it's just one
of those cities that doesn't quite have
i mean there's a few it's basically just
like a few random judo people that kind
of kind of gather together a couple of
times a week but it's not a system a
dojo uh
an instructor
or integrated into a jiu jitsu school or
not
the problem with most judo dojos right
now is that
most of them cater towards the
competitive side
also a lot of them do it recreationally
meaning this isn't how they make a
living so they're there three nights a
week or they're there five even if
they're there five nights a week it's
still only
one junior class and one senior class
and that's it and it's one size fits all
doesn't matter what level you're at it's
one size fits all so
you can't get out of the training what
you're looking to get out of the
training it's whatever the instructor's
teaching you know
and you can't learn because it's not at
the appropriate level for you and
usually you're pushed into doing randori
where you have no choice but to do the
randori part of the training
um
so it's it's a challenge to go learn and
then a lot of times the the schools are
old school
so they go make you do falls for a half
hour they make you do thing you know
make you do things maybe you're a jiu
jitsu person who knows how to fall
already but you haven't proven it to the
judo instructor and they don't break the
norm i say you still have to fall for
six months which turns a lot of people
away as well so it's
you know
it's like any business if you don't
deliver on your customers expectations
you're not going to have very many
customers which is the way it is now
so
a lot of people who listen to this but
in general in the united states practice
brazilian jiu jitsu which has a lot of
similarities to judo as obviously its
origins in judo
how would you compare the two arts from
the perspective of people just
interested about both arts
do you recommend people who do jiu jitsu
get into judo
how can enrich their jiu jitsu how do
you compare the two arts the actual
practice of it and why it might be
useful to you
i mean i think that judo is a hard sport
for adults to do um it just is you know
especially people that are haven't
fallen in a long time haven't you know
aren't very athletic you know haven't
i think i think about my own experience
right outs other than judo when did i
ever do like a forward somersault maybe
when i was in grade school right that's
the last time i've left my feet was in
grade school
most people
haven't got off of a chair or a couch
they spend eight to ten hours a day
either working behind a computer or
sitting on a college watching tv right
and they're not that athletic and they
haven't done anything athletic at least
probably since high school yeah right
that's their last athletic endeavor most
of them so you're talking about as an
adult that's 35 or 40 wanting to start a
sport judo is a really hard sport to
start especially in today's
dojos that don't have a recreational
adult program
or you know when it's one size fits all
it's hard so for those people jiu-jitsu
makes a heck of a lot of sense
good self-defense
it's cerebral where you got to use your
brain you're a smaller person you have
to use technique and you know it teaches
all the same things as judo but it's a
safe way to do it and
because of the validation it has with
the ufc and mma today
right everybody knows jujitsu so now
they can be part of mainstream society
and talk intelligently about what they
see on television or what's going on on
espn today right they have some
knowledge so
they they have an identity and also
there's a good culture in jiu jitsu
where it's becoming a family you know
the dojo is the family place you go to
feel good you go to see your friends you
go to get fit
and you have a good time
right so it makes a lot of sense why
it's growing
judo on the other hand i think is a
better sport for children to do it's
more
i would say
fun and interactive it's a little easier
to teach the kids how to do the throwing
skills and for safety and things like
that their body can handle more than the
adults can they're less likely to get
injured
you know they can it makes them better
athletes because it's a lot more
three-dimensional in my opinion
you know um so i think there's a good
fit between
judo can thrive from kids till
you know whatever high school college
jiu jitsu thrives from that 18 year old
up right right now that's kind of where
it is
so as a dojo you have to kind of focus
on the the teens and the college like
early 20s
that kind of or you need to have if
you're going to be a successful judo
dojo you have to have that
recreational fundamental adult program
in your school where people actually
come to judo learn the moves but aren't
pushed into randori training and pushed
into things where they're uncomfortable
and they can't control the situation
because there's too many unknowns
you uh got an education of browns you're
somebody is amazing because as an
olympian and an olympic coach you always
emphasize kind of balance and
educational
all of that side of life so developing
your brain too so
you are an olympic medalist
a coach of olympic medalists your
business owner so successful in all
these domains
so i have to ask what advice would you
give to young people today high school
judo age high school college undergrad
how to be successful in their career or
just in life in general how to
live a life they can be proud of
i think you have to be true to yourself
you have to decide what it is you really
want to do with your life like
and it's hard because when i grew up i
didn't know i was going to be successful
when i was you know when i was young i
didn't know i was going to be an olympic
medalist i certainly did envision myself
owning a couple of companies that
that makes their living exclusively for
martial arts or judo because that wasn't
really an opportunity when i was a kid
but i've created that opportunity
i would just say that like pick
something that you're passionate about
you know i was stuck in a career before
where i wasn't passionate about it and
it was my wife who said you know jimmy
if you can figure out how to
make your living exclusively from
martial arts
you know where your brain and your heart
and your passion is all towards one
thing that you really like
then you'll be successful and i left the
job i had three kids i was working for
um
monster.com i was in internet marketing
and i was working for that company great
company nothing wrong with the company
but sitting behind the desk from eight
till five and then i get to go to judo
from six until nine at night you know my
whole day is tied up doing something
that i'm really not passionate about she
said if you know if you can figure out
how to make money from your dojo and
other things judo related
then i think you'll be successful and so
she's the one that my wife marie gave me
that advice and i would give that to
others find something that you love
doing where it doesn't feel like work
something you're passionate about and if
the opportunity doesn't exist how to
make money on it you can create the
opportunity
be resourceful figure it out don't let
anybody tell you you can't do it right i
i didn't know that i could have a 200
person judo school that only taught judo
because that really didn't exist in this
country
you know that it actually charges money
like jiu jitsu charges right we're
talking not there's plenty of clubs out
there that charge 10 bucks a month that
might have 100 people but there's not
many that you know with the tuition is
150 a month having 200 people so that's
a successful business
um but it wasn't done before but be
passionate about it understand you're
going to fail understand you're going to
get knocked down beat up
right there's going to be dark days but
you got to persevere you got to believe
in yourself you got to have a plan
you have to be willing to learn from
other people
and that's what i did i i if i didn't
know it i brought somebody in to tell me
what am i doing wrong like look from the
outside what do you see
okay great then you got to be willing to
change you're going to be willing to
adapt
you know and
i think listening believing in myself
and you know creating opportunity and
the other thing is
helping others
something i always did in my in my judo
life
and in my business life
if somebody came to me and asked for
help with hey man is there something you
can do to help me i'm trying to get this
thing started you know i'm trying to get
this this this dojo off the ground or
i'm trying to run this event series or
you know
i was creative and trying to figure out
a way to help them make it work because
if that really was their dream and i
could help them do their dream
i felt like that person would then
give nothing but good good comments
about us good good like they'll remember
it forever
they become like family and they've been
the best advocates for your business
ever and so
the kids that i taught at my dojo were
treated that way the people that worked
for me get treated that way the people
that
my customers that i work with and
building their dojos
get treated that way people that ran
tournaments whether it was grappler's
quest years ago and helping that guy
with a full set of mats for his brian
simmons with his
his thing or
you know
any of the gracies like it just it just
became like family and then i just work
hard and deliver on what i say i'm gonna
do if i say i'm gonna do it i do it
you know and i think it goes a long way
well and i gotta comment so in a small
way i've uh people may not know i think
it's still on youtube we previously
talked many years ago and i remember
it uh you were so kind to me and you
didn't really know who i was you just
took me as a human being you welcomed me
into your dojo and we just had a
conversation on a podcast or whatever
the heck you call that thing
and you were just very kind and
and you were also just
it was the last conversation i had when
i showed up to mit
and it stayed with me
so i've resumed doing this podcast but
it stayed with me because you said
you said that i did a good job at this
and people especially at that time
didn't tell me that
you know didn't and just that that
little act of kindness is probably just
a regular part of your day you had a
busy day it was the end of the day just
saying that that was powerful and and
that pays off somehow
um
so thank you for that yeah
but i was sincere right it was genuine i
felt like
i had been to so many interviews when
it's around the olympic time there's
lots of beat reporters that come out and
they're trying to get your time and
they're just
they're there because they have to get
the story yeah for their newspaper or
their television show and a lot of times
those people show up right and
they pronounce my name wrong or they get
something wrong about the background or
they offend me because
they call me five minutes before that
they're supposed to be there and say oh
sorry we're running late we'll be there
an hour and a half well i'm a busy guy
too and you know like yeah you were
somebody that showed up was so prepared
with your notes knew everything about
like the history of what i had done
the questions you asked were intelligent
questions they were well thought out and
at the end of that that interview i was
really genuinely impressed
and i wanted to let you know you did a
great job because you stood out from the
rest thank you
yeah i mean for me it was like showing
up to like the mecca like the track i
mean i didn't you know you don't always
want to just tell that to people but you
show up
you know of obviously you're the legend
of judo in the united states and so that
was like boston is the mecca
i think that's where you travel
uh to talk to the great so um the the
fact that you were kind to me just stuck
with me for a long time so it pays off
to to to be kind to others to give them
uh
to give them uh
to give them a chance jimmy thank you so
much for giving me another chance and
spending your valuable time and you've
also were kind enough to invite me to
train with you today
at your dojo so i can't wait let's go
let's go do some judo yeah awesome thank
you alex
thanks for listening to this
conversation with jimmy pedro
to support this podcast please check out
our sponsors in the description
and now let me leave you some words from
bruce lee
i fear not the man who has practiced ten
thousand kicks once but i fear the man
who has practiced one kick ten thousand
times
thank you for listening and hope to see
you next time
you